I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little tail of a little big
screws
after the sign
I just woke up
so you get the sleepy
I was like, it was like 4.58, um, like, gets up, crawls to desk, turns on stream.
I might need to- I think I need to have an idle meeting when I'm not sure yet.
But how are you guys doing?
I'm doing fine.
I hope you're doing fine.
I could have slept a little longer, but it's kind of better I don't, because, oh my god,
I'm so big at the hell I'm trying to scroll, so that, um, I'm echoing, I hate it when I do that.
Um, so that, oh, it's my turn to putt.
That should have been a warning sign.
Oh yeah, so I have to wear this on me because YouTube doesn't like my bosom, so I'm hiding it.
Out of shame, I'm so shameful.
I'm so terrible for YouTube.
Um, I am getting a cover-up, uh, eventually, so.
And it'll probably just be my shirt button, which is nice.
I might have got my nose itches.
YouTube does pick and choose, yes.
Um, let me see.
Literally one of my favorite games of all time, plus she be streaming it.
I'm being good today.
Um, I love Inscription.
Inscription is one of my favorite games of all time, so I know some of you guys have that in common.
It is, if you don't know what Inscription is, Inscription is a, um, it's a card, turn-based card
game, and cards have unique properties.
You do all very interesting characters that have very cool little perks that they got.
The ambiance is amazing, the plot is amazing, it's very meta.
I highly recommend, if you've never played Inscription after, um, watching me today,
please play it.
It's such a good game.
I've played through the game multiple times.
Some of you who might be from, um, my PL have seen me play it before, and my Inscription streams
where I know some of people's favorites, because I gave everybody very funny voices.
But yeah, it's a very, very good, uh, good game.
We're going to be doing Casey's Mod, so a Casey's Mod is that it extends the first portion of the
game, because there's several sections of the game.
There's different phases, um, and because, of course, it's the one you first start off with,
the first phase of the game, or the first half, or whatever portion, um, is a fan favorite of
everybody's, um, for the graphics, the characters, what have you.
So Casey's Mod expands that, so it lasts a little bit longer.
We have Crowd Control, I'm going to, I don't, I don't know how it will work with Inscription,
but we'll see.
I'm very excited.
I've never played it with the Crowd Control with Inscription before, so that'll be fun.
Um, somebody also asked, uh, if I'm replacing Strani and the, uh, Uno collab tomorrow, uh,
or, sorry, the day after, or Sunday, I can't remember, I just woke up, let me alone.
Um, yes, I am, because I was supposed to be in it in the first place.
Uh, she only subbed in for me, because I couldn't join because of work.
But now, since I quit my job, I can be back in it.
So I apologize if that disappoints you, I completely understand if it does.
Um, but, yeah, I still hope you think we'll have fun, because I know we will.
Um, yeah, it's no work now, yay.
Saturday, yes.
Um, yeah, it's stupid, Uno only has four players, like it's so dumb,
it should be like six or eight, like at max in my opinion, but you know, it is what it is,
you know, it's owned by Ubisoft, so what the fuck, whatever.
Um, hold on, Uno reverse card.
Uh, the graphic, the thumbnail artist, I was like, I realized after they're like,
oh, what do you want me to put on your thumbnail?
And I'm like, so, and they show me examples of like,
Shawnee's, and it was like, um, stop saying you're inking yourself for five minutes or draw 25.
So, uh, I did stop doing wacky voices for five minutes, but what I should have done
was stop getting demonetized for five minutes or draw 25.
And I thought would have been funner.
Um, but it is what it is.
It's still, it's still silly.
Although like, it was funny that the Azura, the collab I have with Azura,
it did get limited ads, which I thought was really funny.
I don't, I seem to have fallen asleep in excitement.
Well, I'll just talk like this, I guess.
Um, it might be my wifi.
It's, it's been like really hot today.
I wouldn't be surprised if like, I don't know, freaking fire happens or lose power or what have you.
It's just, it's, it's the hottest it's been.
It's been a long time in my area.
Um, but, uh, I did get limited ads, but I appealed it and they accepted it.
It's fine.
So it's good.
Oh, I've woken up.
Um, I, I literally was so tired after, hold on.
Where did my BGM go for just chatting?
Hello?
That's so weird.
I should have it here instead of me just like talking incessantly.
I'll have you have some music with it.
Um, there we go.
That's fine.
Cool beans.
Um, what was I going to say?
Oh, uh, so I went into the grocery store.
I haven't been in the grocery store and ground grocery shopping and like maybe a month or two.
I usually, like, I don't really eat a lot.
I like, you guys, like I'll usually just like door dash a meal and that's my thing for the day,
which I'm like, that's probably not healthy.
Just eating one meal a day.
Hey, but I have like apple juice and water.
So I got some snacks.
I was really pissed though, because I, I'm like, I said, I mentioned like power going out and stuff
on just because in the, um, the frozen food section of my supermarket, the power was out.
So all, I feel bad for the supermarket.
So they're like, you can't open the doors.
I'm like, then why even have this place open if we can't open any of the fast, not the fast food,
the frozen food section.
And like, I was going to get a pizza and or like some like
salmon because I love salmon and I couldn't even do that.
So I literally just got like snacks.
I have, I have, um, Emmy, Mammy, want beef, uh, beef jerky.
So I got beef jerky next to me.
I've already eaten half of a bueno and I have an airhead next to me and I'm like,
I literally went food shopping.
Like I'm a fucking teenager.
But, um, yeah, I have to like actually, I'll probably go to another supermarket tomorrow
and like get like, um, usually I'll get like steak or like some sort of unlike some poultry.
Um, I do, I do, I did see my little, it's funny because people are like, oh,
oh, should you be, you put, you added hello fresh on your alt account.
Oh, did you know you were doing?
Yes, I did.
That was the point.
It was, it was funny because I knew I would get interaction.
You guys have been tricked.
And also, um, I tweeted from that account because I thought it would get more attention
because it has more followers than my main.
But then I was just like, wait, I don't want them to think I'm just a whore
because I'm more than that.
I'm more than just a whore, okay.
Um, so I, that's when I added, I was like, uh, oh shit, add this.
But yeah, you guys can believe the other thing that I did it on accident.
That's okay.
Don't be mad.
You got baited.
I sound like I'm drunk.
I sound like a girl at a party that's like, hey, do you want to come home with me?
Like my ride kind of ditched me.
So like, can you take me home?
No, I've only had like a couple shots.
It's not a big deal.
I'm not going to puke in your car.
Just take me home.
All right.
Thank you.
Um, I'm such a kidder.
Yeah.
Fresh.
She'd be banned.
Um, I wonder if one fourth of your grocery bills is actual hood.
Like, yeah, I got like some Cheerios.
I got milk.
I got like way too much juice, I will say.
I'm like, I got like two, two different types of seltzer.
I got some ginger ale because my tummy has been upset.
I don't drink soda often.
I'm like, you know, I'll make up, I'll make an exception with ginger ale.
That's better.
Right.
Um, it's not.
And then I got some, I realized they got two types of apple juice.
I got apple juice in a pouch.
And then I got apple juice in the, like in the giant container of apple juice,
like a jug of apple juice.
And I was like, well, I thought I grabbed the peach tea, but I grabbed the apple juice.
So I guess I have one apple juice.
And then I got lemonade.
Did I grab lemonade?
I don't know.
And I realized I got milk when I already had milk.
And I'm like, you know, you can never get too much milk.
I don't drink milk because like just like a zero, I'm lactose intolerant.
And I really shouldn't be having milk or gluten for that matter because, uh,
fiber actually, um, dairy and gluten cause inflammation if you didn't know that.
So if you're having inflammation problems, don't eat that stuff.
But, um, I don't live in California where everybody and their mom is like vegetarian
and gluten free or whatever have you.
So I will eat it anyways at the expense of my physical health.
And also because it tastes good.
No one can stop me.
Uh, lactose free.
There was like, honestly, when things say that they're lactose free,
I don't really believe it cause like I'll drink lactate.
I'll still have tummy issues.
I don't know what it is.
There's this other drink.
There's this other type of milk I got that's lactose free.
I still get tummy issues.
So maybe it's another thing within the milk that makes me sick.
I don't know.
It really just makes me fart a lot.
So not a big deal.
Um, like, uh, like I mentioned, like saying that, um, I was watching the boys yesterday
and saying that like in the homelander was like drinking a milkshake.
And I was like, oh, I'd love to drink a milkshake.
And then I got a milkshake this morning.
Surprise.
I treated myself and, um, I was just farting up a storm.
So sorry.
Almond milk.
I don't, my, I don't know.
What it is.
I don't like the texture of most like the only type of milk I can drink.
That's not actual milk.
Milk is probably oat milk.
Almond milk tastes like spit to me.
Um, I also don't like eggnog for that reason.
It feels like spit in my mouth and not like the fun kind.
It's just like someone hacked a loogie and that's,
it's only fun when I do it to you and when it's in a naughty sense,
not when I'm like trying to have cereal.
I don't want to have a spit bowl of spit milk cereal.
I'm good with that, but thank you.
I'm sounding like such a valley girl right now.
What the fuck is going on?
Um, but yeah.
I'm wearing overalls.
I'm going to take them off because they're starting to write up my cooch.
Well, I'm sitting.
I have a song stuck in my head.
K-Tranota and Pink Pantherous did a song together,
which blessed my beautiful bunny ears called Snap My Fingers.
And I have her vocal stuck in my head and I'm like, oh my God.
I love Pink Pantherous.
Oh my God, just stepped in a shit ton of litter.
Um, thank you, uh, by the way, for whomever purchased.
Um, or just like you guys been heavily, heavily, heavily supporting me on Throne.
And I appreciate that a lot because I, as you see, I don't put like
a lot of like weeb shit or clothes or cute shit.
I'm like, I need stuff for my house.
And I appreciate it so much when you guys help me with that.
I'm like, I need a vacuum.
I need, can I have, can I have a bed frame?
I like, oh my God, my bed frame was so heavy and I dropped it on my foot
and I have a giant bruise on my foot now.
Um, that actually doesn't look that bad.
It looks bad when I first happened.
But thank you.
I appreciate you guys so much.
Um, I don't want to sleep on a mattress on the floor anymore.
I don't know how I'm going to, like in my bed is, my bed is big.
I have, um, despite being like just me, I have a king size bed.
Um, because I have three cats and they take up one side of the bed.
And then I was just like, oh, if I get a dog, because when I move,
like probably get my own house, I'm probably gonna get a dog.
I'm like, where's the dog going to sleep?
He's got to sleep in bed with me.
Okay.
Cause you know, I need like have a little puppy.
Um, you know, chilling.
Don't worry.
If I got a dog, I would create, train it.
I'm, I'm very good.
Um, my family friends are dog trainers.
So probably seek their wisdom.
But like, I, I, I also move around.
I'm weird and I also move around a lot in bed.
So my mom always made fun of me cause as a baby, um, or like younger,
I would always sleep in like a crescent shape.
Like, I don't know what, not like my arms out,
but I would just like curl to the ball, like the side of the ball.
And lately when I wake up in bed, I realized if, I don't know if I'm having
restless sleep, but I realized I'm waking up completely sideways.
Like I just, I'm literally horizontal, not vertical on my bed.
And I'm like, good thing I have a giant bed.
So big bed for real little girls to sleep at the foot of the bed.
Exactly.
Hi, Mercy.
I have a little spot for mercy.
It, I like, and then, and it's like, if one of the girls slept over,
which I would love to host the girls at my apartment, if that ever happened,
it would be so funny.
Um, cause I have enough room.
I could probably get like a blowout mattress.
My walking closet is huge.
I could literally fit like a twin in there.
Um, and then someone could take the couch and my couch turns into a bed
cause you girls smart.
And, uh, I have space on my floor and then one of the girls,
I probably could fit two of the girls in bed with me.
So, you know, although like, yeah, I think I'm the tallest out of all the girls.
So I probably, I probably give the girls my bed cause I'm nice like that.
And I'll be like, I'll sleep on the floor.
Uh, yeah.
The couch, honestly, so it's like, um, like, sorry, I just looked over at Boomi
and he, you know that one picture of that cat in that, um, eating food in that one
like feeder food thing and he's, it's like the recording them and stuff.
And then they have names, you know, the one with like the sassy side eye.
I just looked over and he was looking at me like that and it took me by surprise how
much he looks like the cat looking up after eating food going.
Um, you fight for the chance to sleep.
She be, um, but my couch, um, and this is because like I, I have family outside, um,
of my state and sometimes like my parents house is too small to probably like to have
people like stay there.
So I got, um, for my grandparents and my aunts and uncles when they come up from Florida,
um, like, wait, it just stalks my family.
I don't really care though.
I forget it.
I have a, oh my God, Reina is singing the song of her people.
Can you guys hear that?
She has her fuzzy ball and she likes to yell with it.
Um, the couch is like an L shaped couch.
It's kind of small, but like there's this little thing you can pull out and it makes
it turn into a bed and you can put like a little bed pad on it and then just like have
some blankets and I have a lot of blankets and I have so many blankets.
I got you.
So you're not going to be given like a cardboard box to cover yourself in when you sleep over.
Um, if any of the girls watching right now have concern that if you shared the bed with
any of them, you might accidentally straight, just wrangle across like toss and turn to you.
I probably would just smack one of them in the face on accident.
Um, I probably, yeah, I would probably just like flip.
That's why I'm like, I'll sleep on the floor like in my closet.
You could have probably two girls on the couch, three girls in my bed.
So that, yeah, it works out.
Yeah.
The harem can get the cardboard.
You guys can, you guys can sleep next to me on the floor and I'll just, you know,
pull a little piece of cardboard on you for, for warmth.
You can sleep on some cardboard and then you get a cardboard blanket.
I would say thank you if you smacked me in the face.
Um, no, I would never intentionally hit one of the girls unless they're like
subconsciously they tell me to do that while I'm sleeping.
If they're like whispering into me and they're like, hit me, hit me, hit me.
I'm not going to, I also, um, tend to snore.
So I was like thinking about doing for my doughnut on this like sleeping on stream.
I stream and I'm like, I'm definitely going to snore, but that's fine.
I think it's funny.
You can bully me for that.
I don't mind boxing off collab would go kind of hard.
I've always wanted to do kickboxing, um, but my body is nice and frail now
after having COVID and that's what set off the, the, the physical bomb within my body
that gave me fibro.
Do you talk in your sleep?
I don't, I don't sleeping with madam.
I think sleeping streams are allowed on YouTube.
I'm not quite sure.
Uh, I thought with your jujitsu back room and you excel in kickboxing.
Yes.
Like I, but like keep in mind, I haven't, I haven't done jujitsu in quite a
bit because of one.
I injured my shoulder really bad.
Someone tackled me really good.
I don't know if it popped it out of place, but I have like eternal bursitis in that
shoulder.
Oh, hi, bro.
Thank you for the soup.
One of the girls tickling your nose with the feather while the other presents herself.
She's in the way of your hand.
We try to swat away the thing tickling.
I need that as an art piece.
I, I need that drawn.
Thank you for the time.
Yeah.
And COVID stopped us from getting you in the UFC.
Dude, you have no idea.
Cause I was, I was going to start competing at that point.
Um, then COVID happened, which sucked.
But my, my teacher was just like, it's, I think it's time that you start competing.
And I had been there for, um, I forget how long, but I was just like, I was so hyped.
I was so ready.
Then, you know, everybody gets like, it's funny.
People like, oh, you do jujitsu and then it's either they respond with yes or they're
like, nah, I got injured and I'm the latter.
I'm not, I got injured.
I'm no chef, but boy are these titties sweaty today.
I'm sorry.
I was reading something on Twitter.
Um, but it actually fits a lot.
I'm going to retweet that because I was literally taking off my bra at the same time
as I was reading that because my titties are sweaty.
Um, but yeah, and I also bruise really easily.
Uh, I have arthritis at the young age of 56.
So in my neck, I remember I used to, I had to get injections in my neck and I know I
need another one because my shoulder is acting up again because it's all nerve pain and shit.
And that's why my fingers go numb and turn really, really white when I'm cold.
I don't really care though.
And then my customer is like, you could definitely have renoite syndrome.
Um, but, um, uh, I remember I was getting injections in my neck and it was cool because
the way that I was angled, I can kind of see the doctor like putting the needles in because
you had to, he had to put like the ports in first and near my spine.
Um, cause it's like on the lower part of my neck and then, then he had to inject it into
the ports and I could see the ports going into my neck and I was like, holy, this is cool.
I also had a valium that day.
So I probably thought anything was cool.
I never had valium before, but I felt like I was in amnesia, the dark descent.
So I was having a great time.
Um, I had really bad anxiety for that.
So my mom drove me to and from, uh, and so the doctor afterwards, and I'm like on valium,
mind you, and he's just like, so like, do you do a lot of like contact sports?
And I'm like, no, I haven't done a jiu-jitsu for like a year.
And he's just like, yeah, this wouldn't do that.
He's like, do you do any horseback riding?
I'm like, I did when I was like, like years ago.
And they're just like, oh, it looks like you've been doing it recently because your
like neck, it looks like it's been like bobbing a lot.
And I'm like, like it's been jostled and like shaken around and just like,
rut like, like my bones have grinded against each other.
And I'm just like, no, I'm not.
And they're like, do you stand on your head?
Like, do you do yoga?
I'm like, no.
So my bone, like after like, I got hit when I got COVID the first time I was fine.
The second time I was like, I like my body was a mess.
And I like set off like all this fucking inflammation to my body because I was perfectly
fine before I ever had COVID, never had an issue, never had like the worst thing was
that I wore fucking glasses.
So much for that.
Do you stand on your head on a regular basis?
Have you been spending time in a giant novelty washing machine lately?
And, um, yeah.
And so like, I have it in both sides of my neck and in my ankles, like pretty much on my joints.
And they're just, and like, I'm in my 50s, very young for my age.
Okay. So they were very confused by that.
And a lot of doctors wouldn't believe me when I said like, I was feeling this
symptom or that symptom because they're like, oh, that sounds like this rheumatoid or like
fibro or this or that.
And my mom is fibro.
So I was just like, yeah.
So it was just, oh, so fucking annoying dealing with doctors.
Um, even recently, like go to my, I'll go to any doctor and they look at me.
They see like, like I'm a healthy looking woman.
I'm young at 56.
And they're just like, wait, so you have this problem, this problem and this problem.
No, you can't.
You're too young.
And you guys see, have seen how big my titties are.
I'll be honest with you.
I want a reduction because I'm having a lot of horrible back and neck and shoulder pain.
That's, trust me, I love, I love my tick old bitties, but when they cause me pain,
I can't deal with them.
And my, one of the doctors that I went to said, you should just use a different bra.
And I was like, gamer word, excuse me.
No.
Like, brother.
No, no, no, no.
What do you, maybe because it was a fucking man that told me that, but I was, I was pissed the
fuck off.
I was like, excuse me.
You did not just fucking say that.
Um, the anti-grab, yeah, they're like, just wear more sports bras.
I'm like, what?
That doesn't even make any fucking sense.
Um, but this would, I'm like, that's on the back burner though.
That's on the back burner.
I don't even know what I'm talking about this.
Um, I guess, yeah, it's because I've been in a lot of pain lately.
Some were, I think that's another reason I had to like sleep because I've been in a
lot of pain.
My shoulder has been fucking killing me.
So I just want to be honest with you, honest with you, tell you how I'm doing.
Um, I am, you know, we are the Sick Girl Corpo, you know, point, fifth edition because
every Corpo is a Sick Girl Corpo.
Um, learning more, learning more about how Sheeby's body is falling apart.
Um, Pac-Britters is a good name for heavy hand.
That's a good, yeah, actually that's pretty good.
Um, but yeah, please don't get reduction.
Both men and women would kill to have those.
How would I kill you?
How about that?
No, I'm kidding.
In Minecraft, of course.
Um, but you know, like imagine, I'm trying to think I'm an equivalent for men.
It was funny because like Salem didn't quite understand why I wanted one either.
And she's just like, come on.
And I'm like, hold them.
She's like, what?
I'm like, hold them.
So she took them and hold them.
She's like, holy crap, this is like 10 pounds each.
And I'm like, exactly, exactly this.
Um, imagine, yeah, imagine your balls in the, no, like, I can't.
Like take two things of flower, put them in a, like strap them, put a strap on each one of them,
put that strap around your neck and hang yourself.
No, I'm kidding.
And, and hang them around your neck and you're in front of your chest.
Like, or like balloons, not even, no, balloons are too light.
Just like something heavy, take them, um, and do that.
And then feel how bad, and then, and then wear a bra with it, like an underwire bra.
Have that bra dig into you and not fit properly.
Gallons of milk.
Sure, whatever you want.
A bowling.
They're not that heavy.
Jesus Christ.
Um, but there you go.
It's not fun.
It cuts like I have permanent bruising in my shoulders and like, don't get me wrong.
I don't want to do this.
I would, if I didn't have to, but it just hurts.
You know, it just hurts.
It just hurts.
It is what it is.
And I was like, it also, they're not, they make me look a lot bigger than I am.
And I don't know if you noticed in the pictures that I posted on, um, my alt Twitter of like my cosplay,
but you could see like my tits start very high up and towards the like middle of my torso
because they take up a lot of space on my body.
Like, uh, I wish I could hold on.
Let me see if I can find an, uh, oh, this will work.
Oops.
So imagine me having the body type that I do, which is very similar to she be here.
I do have a bit of a tummy, but you know, I have a womb to protect.
So I get a little, a little fat pouch there.
I don't really care about that though.
Um, so imagine my boob and it, it's like fucking this.
Like when you wear a bra and then it makes me look like
that, mind you, this is like anime girl.
So the proportions are going to be a little bit different.
My torso is shorter than my models.
It, it would make me look freaking huge, right?
Like it would make me look fat.
And I've even noticed that because it hides my, um, my curves because I have an hourglass figure
and that's what it does to them.
It hides them.
Obviously they're not that big.
Again, the, my torso is different than my model, but like that's what it does.
And so it makes it look like
that I'm either fat or have huge fucking saggy titties.
And I'm like, brother, give me some cute like B cups.
So I can wear like, I can wear a shirt with no bra, you know, I want to have,
I want to be that powerful, you know?
Um, clown nose bitties, squeeze them honk.
Clown girl for Jen too.
Mom, please.
Mother, please.
I've been persuade.
I've been suede.
Slug girl, clown girl.
Who else do I want?
Um, I want a Lamia now.
I want a bug girl.
I also really want a pet play girl.
Yeah.
Although I already know, like several of the concepts for Jen too, but I just,
a girl likes to dream, you know, there won't be a slime girl.
Moths are overdone.
There's like 50 moths.
Um, a girl, that's a gun that we say.
Honestly, there's not a lot of like, there's like Android V tubers, but like,
there's not object V tubers because you'll have like food V tubers and animal V tubers,
and animal V tubers.
But like, honestly, like, um, like chainsaw man type, like a gun chuba.
I'd be pretty sick.
I wouldn't be averse to that.
This game is super based.
Are guns to it?
Well, what do you mean?
There's so many gun channels on YouTube.
I watched this one guy whose name I has evaded me, but he just like,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's fucked up of me that I like to watch like the different types of
bullets they use in different types of, I also like to see how guns work in real life versus
the games that I use them with, like play them in, play them with.
And oh my God, what the fuck is his name?
I have to look it up and he uses like those gel bodies and he's like in the middle of
like a desert and I don't know, like, I can't remember where he is at.
He's like the middle, not of a desert, but it's like, it looks like Cali, but I don't
think it's Cali.
Um, and he just shoots it with his friends and they just
are pretty, they're just, they just fuck about and it's funny.
Garen Thump.
Yes.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Garen Thump.
Yep.
That's him.
Yeah.
That's, that's the guy.
I want to get my, my, my, my license to carry.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Um, I've always wanted to learn how to shoot.
My grandfather tried to teach me how to learn how to shoot, but then my mom said no.
And I was sad.
And it's funny though, because my mom has literally worked as part of her job before.
She worked with a, uh, a, a team of SEALs and for some like team bonding exercise,
she learned how to clear rooms and shoot.
And she was like the best shooter.
And one of the, my mom was telling me that one of the soldiers is like flirting with her.
And saying how good of a shot she was.
And she's like, he, he, he, he, he, he.
And my mom's like very like, sort of scared of like, does it like violence?
And I'm like, mom, be fucking for real.
Like in my life, my mom probably would have been in the military or running a 14, 500 company.
Cause she's that badass.
Um, Spec Ops mom.
Yeah.
No, she's a, she's a good shot.
She is.
My mom's badass.
I don't think my, I don't think my dad's ever shot like at a range or anything.
I have to ask him.
Um, I don't know if he even wears that.
She V's father is some random SEAL, dude.
No, this, I was around.
This is not before I was born.
Well, yeah, I'm, I'm also, I'm pretty good with the airsoft rifle and I'm very good at archery
from camp.
Um, so not to my own horn.
Uh, but I do like, I do like shooting.
I think it's really good way to release like pent up stress.
Um, especially you're doing it in a safe environment.
I would love to get lessons.
Um, I do have some friends who are military.
So like harem's airsoft one, that'd be fun.
Oh, like a paintball off collab would be sick.
Um, previous girl scout credentials.
Are there any SEAL tubers?
Yeah, there's a few.
Oh, like I thought you meant like SEALs, like the animal.
Um, no, this, I don't, there's the only military related person I can think of as the horse.
Uh, is it Tomoe or Tomo?
She's like a horse girl.
Um, and there's definitely, there's not a lot of military oriented.
Like they'll have like old school, general artwork of them, but they're not like actually
like military base.
You know, there's a, there's a niche there.
There's a niche there at some airsoft stuff to throw.
No, where am I going to use it?
I don't, there's no ranges near me.
Umari Tomo.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, sir.
She's cool.
Um, I love her, her character's design.
Um, close enough.
Well, I can't pretty guys know, I can't pronounce Japanese names.
Uh, a few tactical VTubers.
And then I don't know where VSPO EN is.
I always call them vispo.
Um, like where are they?
Where are they?
Where's their gen?
Where's the EN gen?
I applied for that a year ago.
They gave me a few views, but of course you sell.
I didn't get a call back.
I'm happy I didn't be alert.
Um, because again, I told you guys I used to do a lot of, uh, FPS games.
So I thought I could make it in.
And this is even before I became a VTuber,
like before I even was Rena.
So I just applied as myself, just normal me.
Um, what gun did I shoot before?
I don't know.
I remember I shot a rifle.
Uh, it was like a type of rifle.
I don't know.
I can't remember that shit.
Just because I watch gun stuff doesn't mean I know what everything's about.
The SPO has the highest standards in industry because you have to be good at it.
But they're like, but then again, like think about who owns the SPO.
Or I was calling VISPO because it's fun.
Owns VESPA.
VISPO.
Um, Brave Group.
And Brave Group has already seen how successful that, um,
before Mariah and Globi are in their normal gens.
And I think I'm missing one, but I forget.
Um, there are a lot of FPS girls, girlies.
I don't know.
I'm like, maybe they're being trained.
Maybe they're, maybe they scrapped the project and focused on V for Mariah.
I don't know.
But, and I know like they want to do competitive gaming as well.
So, oh, thank you, boy, for the 10 gifted.
Oh, thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
You rise up.
But, um, yeah, sometimes.
And then actually, can we, can we just like talk about like VTubing stuff for a second?
Like, I'm not a, I'm someone who's very interested in the comings and goings of the
VTubing industry and community stuff.
And I tweeted yesterday as a joke, um, that I'm like, I'm going to hijack TVS.
Okay.
Things that VTubers say run by a false ID, uh, because he hasn't been covering small
Corpo stuff and only like needy shit and someone called like someone fucking tagged
him in it like he liked the tweet and I was like, lol, I was kidding.
Cause I'm going to make my own.
I like, I definitely want to make some of you.
I used to be a commentator, YouTuber.
Um, and I would like to do an unbiased, uh, what's it called, just like segment, not like
too long, just talking about smaller agency news, cause that's been sorely lacking for
the last little bit.
Um, so I feel like that would be fun.
Damn, you done it all.
Yeah.
Again, you guys, I said it before, I used to work for VTubing.
Um, I, this wouldn't be drama based.
I wouldn't, I would probably, uh, and I would also like look to you guys as like a resource.
I'm smacking my headphones, um, to like be like, oh, what do you think I should talk
about?
Or like maybe make him into shorts, um, just but like only focus on agency VTubers.
Cause I think that would be fun.
Um, and Shawnee was like, hell yeah.
And I was like, yeah.
And then Shawnee's been supporting a lot of my ideas lately.
And I'm like, yeah, I'm going to be like, I'm going to be like, I'm going to be like,
so I want to like think of a name and stuff and get that ball rolling.
I've been thinking about it before like back when I was Renna that I would do something
like that, um, but I would cover like all news, but as an indie, but now being agency,
I would rather just want to cover other like my agency and other agencies.
Um, I know that might be a conflict of interest.
I get that.
Um, but I would probably only like objectively just say like, hey, this is what's going on.
I'm not injecting feeling into it.
Um, so be sucky VTuber news.
Uh, should be news.
Yeah, if you count me in.
I'm going to have this TV, yeah.
Um, actually, I was very thankful he didn't cover us because I think we've got,
we've gotten more hate.
Um, I've said before that when him and other VTubers first covered us debuting or being
created in any mention of it, uh, they focused more in the negative comments
or assumptions of the company.
Um, and I feel like they might do the same if they covered us again, although because
he liked my tweet, I'm kind of worried.
I'm just like, oh, fuck, is he going to cover us for the next one?
So who knows?
Um, but whatever the fucking hat, no, it is what it is rabbit hole news.
Are you funny?
Um, but yeah.
And then I'm like, I can like, I can't do, I have to make drama to get on, but that's not
my goal.
I don't want to, I don't like drama.
I don't, um, I would, you could ask anybody that I'm friends with, uh, in the girls.
Like I'm someone who if I hear anything like whispers of unrest, I'm like, let's get to
the bottom of it.
Let's talk, let's do this.
What's going on?
Not that that hasn't even happened, but they just know I'm that type of person.
Um, there's not such a thing as bad publicity.
I think there is for our case, just because of the content we do, uh, I don't know.
Like I just feel like for us would be more of a detriment to our brand, but, and then
just show how unprofessional we are.
If I like, if we got into any sort of that stuff, um, sure drama alert girl.
Um, haters gonna hate.
Yeah.
And it's like, and it's bad if it messes with your mental health.
Yes.
I wouldn't want to, I'm like, I'm here to talk about what's happened.
I don't want to talk about how these two girls are bitching at each other because this,
this and that happened.
I'm going to say, yeah, I'm not, I don't care about that stuff.
It is disappointing when there's really never any updates on something that does
is negative.
Yeah, it is.
It's kind of a let down, uh, cause like I'm always someone who I'm like, celebrate the
little victories.
Um, and lately, anytime I look at something VTuber news related or VTuber related, um,
or like coverage of it, it's usually something negative and it makes me sad because there's
a bunch of like good things happening in the community every day.
Um, but then again, like that's not, the news doesn't report like the regular news doesn't
report unhappy things anymore either.
I don't even watch news, like actual like human news anymore because they don't report
on anything.
Like it's usually like tragedy or like something bad or the weather.
Um, so, and then I totally get why he would do that because Nidhi was up his ass.
He's like, let me go up his ass.
Let me go up their ass.
And I'm like, you know what?
I got it.
Um, but I liked to watch it when I was an indie so I could see what like kind of what
the tone was for agencies.
Um, and also like what indies were doing in the, in the VTuber community because I just,
I want to know everybody was up to, um, now I just don't watch any of it at all.
I just listened.
I like to listen to like video essays now about like things that have happened in the
past.
Um, I think that's interesting because I like to educate myself on VTuber history because
again, I've only been a VTuber for six months.
I've known and been part of the community and a consumer of VTubers since they, um,
since they've been around, um, since they started back like before in like 2019 or even
further than that.
But I never was like in it in it, you know, VTuber weather segment.
It'd be really funny.
I'm out in a weather segment.
I would just make makeup like random fake places and be like, it's currently sunny in
Topeka.
What is it?
It's raining in Topeka.
It was something like foster's home for measuring friends.
Um, hop, happy, hoppy news tonight at 8 p.m.
Happy, hoppy news tonight at 8 p.m.
With your hottie host, Sheebie.
I'd have to work on my transatlantic accent because I can't, um, it's, it would be hard to
because I need to do like the news voice.
And tonight we're expecting a light drizzle in Wonderland.
Later tonight at 6 p.m.
What is strongy shoving up her ass?
Oh my God.
Where are my mods?
They're gone.
They're like, she's late an hour.
I can't do it.
I'll do it myself.
Tomorrow, it's going to be raining urine.
So make sure you have your umbrellas or open your mouth.
Um, sometimes I sound like I'm from a commercial and I do that.
Strongy catching strings.
Hey guys, can we not, can we stop talking about my investor in the chat?
Thank you.
Kisses.
Unnecessary speculation going on about where people are from, which is,
you don't need to know because it doesn't matter.
Just enjoy their content.
Um, that's a meme if I ever heard it.
The rabbit's foot segment goes, and it's just me stepping like just like heel clacking noises.
That'd be funny.
There is an Aurora Borealis localized entirely in Icy's kitchen.
How is she doing it?
Tonight at BunnyBun capacity, what's going into she being and how much?
That was good.
That was, that was good.
I'll give you that.
Okay.
Need a quick look back.
Oh, but, but, and then like also like, um, I would just, I just like to talk about VTubers.
Like it was cool.
I'm very excited to see the debuts for the new EN girls from Hall of Live.
I didn't anticipate for them, for there to be a new gen so soon.
I thought it was going to be a couple more months.
Um, although everybody had kind of already surmised who was going to be who, but you know,
like training and all that.
And I'm wondering if they were hired on or scouted previously because models don't
take a very long time to make unless they cranked them out because I know they have in-house people.
And they have obviously being Hall of Live have pulled in the industry.
But, um, uh, Raora Panthera, I can't pronounce anybody's names.
Please don't hurt me.
Raora Panthera, I love her design.
I love her concept is so true to her.
If you know who she is, uh, being an amazing artist and everything.
I really like the short stack.
Um, I feel like she'll be really silly.
And then I feel like Blood Flame, Elizabeth Rose Blood Flame is just
Narissa Red.
Narissa in red.
Um, so, but I like, I, everybody's, and then I was
chuckling at the automaton's last name, Immigrate.
And then I'm like, she kind of looks like mint, but they look amazing.
They look amazing.
Like, and she probably does plays violin or does some sort of music.
And so I can't wait to see the type of talents they'll possess and everything.
And just like, how fun they'll be.
I usually, I usually don't watch, um, Hollow Live or Niji just because
I don't want to fall in love again.
She worry.
Um, but, uh, it's, and it's also hard because you don't get the intimacy of a smaller
streamer in chat.
That's why I like smaller agencies.
And that's why my Oshi is in the smaller agency.
Um, so it's, yeah.
Yeah.
Trony does give us this Scorches style.
Yeah, my favorite is Rod Bunny is live.
How's it going?
We're going, we're doing all that.
Okay.
I'm agreeing.
Sounds like an intro.
Irma Gurd.
Everybody sounds like Irma Gurd names.
Yeah, that's true.
That's funny.
Um, yeah, just, it's, it's, it just stay, and you can usually only
communicate through like, text-to-speech donations.
Um, which is funny because it makes for amazing clips and everything.
And people write some really funny shit, but like, I like this.
I can read chat.
I honestly probably know all of you.
It's like, right now I don't really see a lot of unfamiliar faces.
So I have my regulars.
And so it's very nice to have a closer intimate fan base.
Who is my Oshi?
You don't need to know.
That's for me to know and you to never to find out.
She's mine.
I'm gatekeeping her.
Okay.
Thank you.
Um, model actually is a violin, plays a bassoon, calling it now.
I bet she's multi-talented.
I bet she can like, play piano and stuff.
Um, name a salt.
Well, I'm not going to read your names right now.
Oh wait, I see a new name.
You must be a lurker.
But thank you guys.
If you're new and you remembered, um, I am, I do recognize a lot of you,
but so don't think I don't know who you are.
I appreciate all of you.
Especially my lurkers.
Because even though you don't talk, you're still watching.
You still got me in the background.
And I care about you for that.
Thank you.
Um, she remembers.
Um, I do be lurking though.
Yeah, that's fine.
I lurk.
I, I don't talk.
Wind streams.
Um, because like, I have like a whole alt account.
Like, not, not even like Rena.
Um, like I have like my own personal account that I like, I watch VTubers on.
And I just lurk.
I don't say anything.
Um, and like, yeah, I'm trying to think.
I think I only, the only time I ever talked was when Strawny,
Strawny was someplace else.
And that's, and like, that's how you like, I don't talk in streams.
And then she got me to want to talk in streams.
That's how amazing she is.
Yeah, and I usually have streams in the background too for background noise.
I know a lot of you guys do that or like, and because I know sometimes I stream
when people are working.
Um, so yeah, speaking of streaming, I haven't started the game yet,
but I kind of feel like yapping because this is going to be a long stream.
Um, I'm, maybe this will be an endurance stream, uh, just because, um, I love this game.
And I love spending time with you guys.
Um, I'm just ashamed of my green name status.
That's why I lurk.
Oh, yeah, hide yourself.
I don't show your face.
Gray name, terrible.
No, I'm kidding.
Um, but, uh, even if you're not green and your name is gray, don't think I don't appreciate you.
Um, I just appreciate you less now.
Ow, hurt my rib laughing like that.
Um, also, um, Immi, I think is going live right now.
So if you wanted to go see Immi, uh, I forget what she's playing,
but you can go check her out.
Um, her, her info is in my description as well.
Um, what build do you tend to go for?
I kind of just wing it every run.
I used to abuse the Orborus.
Oh, thank you for the 10 gifted authority.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Speaking of which, I don't know if anybody, I don't have my headphones on,
so I can't hear if somebody like don't know.
Let me look.
I need, I'm, I might get IEMs.
Um, what do I mean?
I remember what they're called, but like the essentially earbuds,
just because headphones with my glasses on hurt my ears.
They're the ones that these are in ear monitors.
Yeah.
Um,
You just get more spit from Georgia Tech U.
Um, but no, like if you show up, that's all that matters to me.
Um, I also decided because I'm starting to think it's causing
somewhere divide between everybody's fan bases.
I don't mind if you have somebody else's Oshimarks in your name.
I was doing it for Kayfabe, um, but I'm realizing I don't like,
like I'm pretending to be mad because you like somebody else.
It's you can like multiple streamers, especially ones in our gen.
Um, and yeah, I just
I don't know.
I've been here since be a lure first form on Twitter.
I feel like an old woman.
Can't wait to see you all grow and have the privilege of looking back on these streams.
Oh, yeah.
It's, I've been there since the beginning too.
So I'm right there with you, sis.
I can't see a new she beat.
It's for me, not you.
Keep it in the family.
Yeah.
That's how what I'll say.
You can keep it in the family.
Although like, but it's funny because I'll like,
I'll see other people's Oh, she marks.
Like I think I saw like a Maya whispers and like she's a, oh my God,
a giant fucking June bug just landed on my window and scared the shit out of me.
Holy crap.
The thing is huge.
Um, staring at me.
But like, I like a Maya whisper.
She's a good, you know, as martyrs and stuff.
So I'm like, I don't really care.
Um, I just like, I just, I'm a type of person and I think that's why me and
strongy are so much alike that I'm like, just support everybody.
If you can do what you can.
If you want, cause you know, everybody's so talented.
Everybody's so cool.
Cause like, I love a lot of the other agency girls.
Again, I used to be indie.
I followed and looked up to a lot of the people that are, yeah, but so I'm like, I can't be like,
Oh my God, don't hate me.
Don't, don't, don't stop.
Can't love.
You have to love me more.
I just want you to love me more or less.
Um, and I think, yeah, I think, I think it's a healthier mentality for me.
Cause I do, I, I'll be honest with you.
I do get jealous and I realize feeding into that mindset for me for kayfabe is,
is actually not good for me.
Um, cause I remember back when I was Rina, I would feel immense jealousy when something happens.
And now I'm just like, no, I've kind of grown from that.
Um, cause I'm just like, why am I upset that somebody else is supporting a streamer that I also enjoy?
I'm like, fuck that.
No, like that's, no.
But, um, again, and another thing, cause I was asking Mercy to explain it to me.
Um, because I know she, she, uh, she gets bothered by stuff.
Um, so she was explaining to, I smacked my mic, explaining to me like, oh, she culture,
like, and what, how, what oh, she's mean and commie.
Not that I didn't know already, but just like on a deeper level, like really picking it apart
and like telling me, so I really appreciated her to do that.
Cause then I understand.
I'm like, oh, I got it.
I understand.
I get it.
Like not this.
Thank you for explaining it to me.
Um, don't want to put sugar in chat.
I do, again, I, again, I do, if you, I do want you to be collared to me, but I can't force you to do that.
Um, there's just she be only she be, and I've also kind of just decided and then like,
cause I was talking to a straw knee and one of the managers about it too.
Um, I think I put too much effort in stock into a kayfabe, um, which is my kayfabe is,
you know, dummy mommy mistress.
Oh, I'm going to step on you.
When the reason I was hired was because of my voice and my personality.
I wasn't, it's not like I'm acting and cast to play an actual character.
That's not what V tubing is.
Uh, it's like who's line is it anyway?
Where the points don't matter.
The kayfabe barely fucking matters only for like assets.
A little bit of backstory for your appearance, vice versa.
Um, kayfabe, if you don't know is a wrestling term, which is like your lore, your backstory,
your history of their character that you play.
Um, and I was just, and this might filter some people and that's fine.
And I was talking to strongy and one of the managers about it and I was just like, I had,
I said to her, I'm like, I realized the other day because I was having so much imposter syndrome
because I was like getting so worked up that I wasn't good enough to be she be.
And then strong is like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, shut up.
Like you were always meant to be she be you were my she be.
I didn't pick you because you could be a dummy mommy because I wasn't.
If you guys don't know who I was, I was Rina who was a fucking lolly sub bitch brown cat.
Like I'm total opposite of me.
She's like, I picked you for you.
And I'm like, you know what?
And that goes for the other girls.
She picked us for us, not the characters we play.
But like I enjoy playing into the dummy mommy.
Like don't don't get me wrong.
I do like doing that.
Um, because I do like, you know, getting you guys little riles up.
Oh, um, and I was just like, you know what?
You're fucking right.
I'm not going to have imposter syndrome anymore because she picked me out of hundreds of other
people just because I'm a goofy motherfucker.
Okay.
She watched, she sat down and watched my streams.
The team that she hired also like she selected me and then she went to the team was like,
what do you guys think?
And they're like, oh yeah, 100%.
She's our first choice.
So at the end of the day, I'm just going to be me.
You'll get dumb.
You'll get girl fail.
You'll get this.
You get that.
Um, and that's made me feel so much more better.
Just real.
I'm like, and it's funny because nobody fucking cares about kayfabe in the VTuber community,
except lately for us.
I'm like, nobody usually cares about fucking lore.
But suddenly everybody cares about us.
Stick it to our fucking lore.
You can't see.
I'm shaking my hands, leaning back.
Um, and yeah, I'm like, I'm just, and I'm not saying this because like I'm angry or anything.
I'm just saying this because like I've come to the realization.
Like I, I'm becoming more comfortable being she be like, I feel like she's me now
because I'm acting as myself.
I'm not pretending to be someone I'm not because then you just get burnt out and you
just get unhappy.
And that's where a lot of VTubers crash and burn is because they think they have to
play an actual character when in fact they were just hired for their voice
and for who they were in their content prior to being cast.
Um, but yeah, uh, also new.
Yeah, I'm new.
Like, don't forget that I haven't finished VTuber for long.
Um, for ABVTubers, it's not kfave, it's anti-tax, which are on my Patreon.
Like you still get that stuff on my Patreon.
Um, yeah, I think everybody shouldn't care that much about stuff because like, look at
Icy, she's supposed to be a brat.
She's so cute and sweet.
That's fine.
And then look at Amy, she was supposed to be the sweet and cute one and she's a brat.
And that's great.
And then Azura is, you know, she's like quirky, funny, um, giggly little goat.
And she's not like, oh, my sweet little boy all the time.
That's fine.
And then like, you know, strongy is strongy.
And then Mercy's Mercy.
And like you guys fall in love with us because of us, not because of the,
because of our pat, like our fake kfave, you know?
And yeah, it's great.
Like it's not even Gap Moe, like, because it doesn't matter that much because we were
meant to be these people.
Azura is also a brat.
Ooh, I didn't know that.
Like, oh yeah, we're, we're a wacky little gang.
I'm just a funky little rabbit.
Um, yeah.
And the chemistry is authentic.
Um, bad of anatomy.
I added to my schedule next week a drawing stream.
So I hope you guys will enjoy that.
Um, yes.
And it's like, I don't have to be that.
That's, that's in the other content that's in the Patreon.
And I don't want you guys to put so much pressure on yourselves or the girls to be
like, oh, like, I know a lot of people don't watch me because they're like, oh,
I'm not into hard fandom.
But I'm like, I'm not doming the chat 24 seven.
Like that's not like, give everybody a chance because I think you'll be pleasantly surprised.
Like you probably are watching me right now saying, oh, I don't think I'd like one of the
smaller girls because I like big jugs.
Um, yeah, but like, Amy's funny as fuck.
So go watch her.
She's just as base as I am, if not more.
I know she's definitely more than me.
But, uh, yeah, just here to be entertained.
Oops, all brass.
Uh, but it's, it's like, is it?
Yeah, you're supposed to be dominant, but you show up.
No, no, no, I'm not supposed to be anything.
I'm just supposed to be myself.
And that's the mindset.
I want to teach you guys is that all the girls are not supposed to be this, this, or that
because of a kayfabe and like a character design.
We're just us.
I'm just she be and you're just can.
Um, she's telling us by teaching us, but like, naturally, I'll still pull out like,
you know, don't get it twisted.
I still will beat you when you're naughty because I like that part of my kayfube.
I like leaning into that.
And the girls do like, do like leaning into different parts of theirs.
Um, but I just wanted to make that distinction for everyone that we were hired to be us.
And I don't want you to get so wrapped up, you, the viewer, you, the fan to get so wrapped up
and want somebody, um, should be like due to their lore that you don't enjoy their, their,
their content because you can enjoy.
So like, I'm not gonna, let me, I'm trying to think of somebody.
Uh, I'm not a huge fan of mystery novels.
Does that mean I'm going to hate Amelia Watson?
No, she's funny because she's, she'll play into stuff sometimes, but she's not constantly
searching for mysteries.
Um, who am I?
I'm she be.
I'm she be just me.
You can find out who I am by watching me stream.
You aren't enough.
Atmospheric people make your mom jokes and such.
That's what I like.
I'm not big into Dom in general.
And it's like how she be expresses herself.
Yeah, exactly.
I want you to watch me for me.
Not because of the tags that are associated with my ASMR content on Patreon.
You know, um, what do you mean she's not detective?
The real mystery was the friend she made along the way.
Oh, hi.
Feeling like I can hire Amelia to find my dad.
Oh my God.
Oh, really?
I can find your mom in these.
Your mom.
I like listening to your voices soothing.
Yeah, I'm a yapper.
I'm a yappiest yabbit in all the West.
I mean, you don't own a brothel.
No, I do.
Don't, that's actually real.
Sorry.
But please, in short, give all the girls a chance.
Just because you don't like a certain tag doesn't mean you won't enjoy their content.
Because we're all just cute girls doing cute things.
And I would hate for you to miss out on cute girls being cute.
You know?
If you have another Oshimark besides Madams,
nook if you book.
Nook if you book.
Right.
No, if you book.
Instantly plays.
Get ready.
Thank you for the tip, Anonymous.
I think when I see somebody else's Oshimark, I just know that
you are really passionate about other creators.
And I know you still like me.
And I've learned not to take personally that you like us in different ways.
And there's only so many characters you can do to put in somebody's name.
I see people with a bazillion Oshimarks in their name.
It looks fucking cluttered.
So I get it if you just want one.
Because then I recognize the majority of them.
Like there's one that's Azura's.
And I'm like, yeah, I love Azura.
Or if it was somebody else.
Oh, yeah, I see Stroneys.
Yeah, I love Stroneys.
Or if it was like some girl from Pixelink.
Oh, yeah, I love Kana.
You know?
It's yeah, so nice knowing people support my friends.
That's all I care about.
I am the type of person as a streamer that if I ever got like
blew the fuck up, I would be doing everything in my power.
Literally.
This is why I want to join a vealer because
Stroneys doing exactly what I wanted to do.
I'm like, I just want to raise up smaller creators to a bigger platform
and support them and give them stuff so they can do whatever they want.
And have a great time and chase their creative dreams.
That's what I would fucking want too.
What if you don't like Lawley?
I don't know what to tell you.
Uh.
Start liking them.
I don't know if you don't like the body type.
It's like, yeah, people don't like, I won't watch some streamers
because I don't like the art style of their model.
So I totally get that.
I'm like, I'm not into super Western eyes.
Like mine's a little bit Western, but not too much art styles.
So like, that's fine.
I'm not going to fuck them.
Yeah, but like, I used to also not like that type of body type model
than I watched.
Uh, who was it?
I forget who it was.
What the fuck was it?
Are they graduate?
I think they graduated and that's my camera.
They're on the top of my head because I haven't watched them in a while.
But then I was like, oh my God, wait, this bitch is funny.
Oh, she's a really good voice actress.
And I like wondered how like people sometimes, you know,
girls put on voices and some don't.
I'm like, wow, um, all that stuff.
I don't watch almost all male vTubers because of the same reason
I can still watch some of their funny and nice.
Yeah.
I usually don't watch male vTubers, uh, because I just can't really,
I just can't really, um, what's it called?
Relate to them because I like, some of them have like really bro streams.
Um, so I'm just like, this is for them.
This is for the, this is for the bros.
You're like, this isn't for me.
Um, and then some of them are also very BFE, which makes me cringe out of my fucking mind.
But like, I've watched like one or two clips, but it just isn't for me.
But everybody has their preferences.
You're allowed, you're allowed preferences.
Um, skill issue.
If you don't like that.
That's funny.
There's this difference between a vTuber with a small frame and lolly little for me.
Yeah.
There's also that.
I agree.
Cause like, I look at like, uh, Amy Asami and she's not, she's like small, but she's not lolly.
You know, like, I was like looking at pretty lady.
I know I prefer to look at pretty ladies.
And also, I'll be honest with you, another reason I don't watch male vTubers
is because, um, they are so limited in their outfits and they're rigging.
Like I'm sorry, but I've seen so much better rigging for female vTubers.
And because like just the movement of female vTubers, I don't know what it is.
It's just, it's just different and men are like the male vTubers usually very stiff.
Um, I've seen a couple with really good rigs because like I'm someone who I look at when I
watch a streamer, I appreciate the art, uh, behind it all, like in terms of the actual art
and the rigging.
Um, and a lot of male vTubers just fucking don't have good fucking rigging or they also
have like really boring ass toggles.
So I'm sorry.
Male vTubers don't, don't, don't cover my neck please.
Bald physics.
So when, yeah, when we get the best designs, I'm like,
I'm tired.
I'm seeing the same fucking, fucking Ikemen, Ikemen.
I can't pronounce it.
You can make fun of me.
It's fine.
Style.
Like you all dress the same in different fonts.
I'm done.
Thank you.
Enjoy the, enjoy those emotes, girly pop.
Um, can't really watch you vTubers.
vTubers is not my cup of tea.
Brother, what are you doing here?
What are you, what are you doing?
This, this agency.
Brother, I think you're lost.
Um, it's just like in video games, female characters always look better.
Yeah, literally.
No, that's why so many dudes just play female characters.
My dad will play female characters when he plays games.
And I remember, I remember like, I'll just like be ragging on them for it.
I'm like, dad, why are you this chick with big titties?
He's like, because she got big titties.
And I'm like, look at her and she's dressed way better.
Look at all the dudes skins versus the girl skins.
And I'm like, you know what, you're fucking right, dad.
Um, Facebook shop blocks go hard.
We were hot men in games.
It'd be that simple.
If I can create a kid.
Yeah, women have like so much funner's things.
Like I remember when I played Baldur's Gate for the first time,
I was like, okay, I'll make a girl and a boy.
Baldur's Gate 3.
So I made a girl.
She was just really cute, like, elven, for like dark, for like,
I can't fucking remember what I made her.
But she was like tan skin, bright red hair, freckles,
really cool, like tattoos, all this other shit, like makeup, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then I went to the do the dude and I'm like,
okay, I can do beard one, two, three, four, five.
I can change the eye color.
I can give him a scar.
Women pretty.
Dress up is, I love dressing up like in like games,
like I'll usually take like, I take forever.
The majority of me playing Elden Ring,
probably like 50 of those hours is me just like trying to look pretty.
Men get toothpick or burly.
Literally, literally though.
I'm picking guys too, but the options be limited.
Whenever it comes to RPG stuff, I always make a male, female,
self-insert, but I often play the female character more often,
even though I'm a guy.
Yeah, it's just more appealing to look at.
And like, I'll like growing up, I usually played a lot of male characters,
just because I didn't like being pointed out,
being female and just kind of like griefed in, in games and stuff.
And I'll be honest with you, I probably made the same character over and over and over again,
just some emo looking dude.
Some emo like looking twink was my character throughout the years.
I'm just like black hair, eyes, some gothy looking outfit in your golden.
And that's what I did.
And then I did it because I didn't want to play a female and be all like,
and be the center of attention.
Oh gee, can you date me?
Literally though, literally, I would just get like, oh, I just, I couldn't.
And that's why I like, I didn't, I didn't, I wouldn't talk in like, game lobbies.
The same reason too.
We need she be to play Stila Blade.
You just want me to drool in like, the entire time.
Ah, so Shibani is, she'd be his ideal man.
Are you a girl?
Or just like people be like, hey, let's be friends.
And then they try to like, just like,
E-sexing you up.
Oh, we'll have some straights this mail.
Um, just be so cool.
I remember people used to say, uh, call like, say grill, like G-R-I-L-L.
Cause I think, or like, man, like I would play Wolf Quest.
And which I'm going to be playing next week as well.
We're playing fucking Wolf Quest.
And we're going to go find a mate and have puppies.
And, um, and, uh, people would say grail, grill.
As in like cook, as like mail, as in like M-A-I-L.
Cause people kept asking about it.
And they would just do, to fucking so much E-sex and Wolf Quest.
I used to say I was a boy in every game straight out.
Cause I was like, yes, literally, four gets it.
A hundred percent.
I would literally just do that.
I remember I went by like a mail version of my IRL name.
And I remember I had the girlies still fucking falling for me though.
You know, nobody can, I need a, I need a lip bite toggle.
And we have to ask mom for that.
Mom, can I, can I get a lip bite toggle?
So I could be like, wait, can I, no, I can't do anything similar.
Shaboris.
Yeah, I was Shaboris all the time.
Insane aura.
And uh, yeah, it was just, it was just easier.
And then I would have to tell the girlies.
They'll be like, why don't you get a voice call with me?
And I'm like, types out, sorry babe.
Uh, I'm too shy.
Yeah, I remember I was like, I'm guy on the line as a dude for a bit.
And I was a girl.
How many female moms?
Mike doesn't work.
Sorry, my mic's broken.
Baby case.
Oh, if I was a dude or if I was a lesbian, I would be a fucking menace to society.
I would be a womanizer.
I just feel like I would be the shittiest fucking dude.
I would just be the opposite because like me, I'm a very sweet, very caring,
I'm a very affectionate, lovable person if I really like you.
I am very protective over people that I care about,
but I just feel like if I was a dude, I'd just be a piece of shit.
I would definitely be an F boy.
I think I would be a fuck boy.
Hey, you wanna be my discord kid?
I would love to see my hands as a necklace around your neck, baby girl.
Some pictures of your asshole.
Can you mail for me, kitten?
Dad actually, no, I'm above that.
Tom boy, she be when I'm already a tomboy.
I think, I think I am in my tomboy.
I don't know.
I was like very, again, growing up, I was always taller than all the boys
and I've always been very, very fucking strong.
I remember one time I was playing basketball with these kids and I don't know why I did this,
but I picked one of the guys up off the ground and I threw him back down
to get the basketball from him and he started crying and I called him a little bitch.
And I'm like, why are you crying?
And then he's just like, and I was like, we were like 14.
It's not like we were like seven.
It's like we were like 14.
And I like chucked him.
And then I also used to play a lot of football at my after school program
because we had a lot of sports there.
So it was very like my after school program was very athletic.
And so we would play football.
I would be fucking mowing down the boys in my grade.
American football.
Yes.
And soccer too.
And you know, European football.
I would be mowing down motherfuckers.
I wasn't a bully.
I was just bigger and stronger than people.
I can't help it.
I would fucking everybody.
I was like five, six at age 14.
What do you want me to do?
I'm sorry.
All you bros were fucking five feet tall.
What do you expect me to do?
I'm going to fucking roundhouse kick you to the face.
I'm five, six.
I'm taller than you.
Bro, I'm five, eight.
I'm so sorry.
Have you stiff arm?
I don't know what that means.
Like, I don't know what that means actually.
They're five feet and 14 at their time.
Flexing female puberty.
It's true though.
It's true.
I remember I was like, how old was I?
Because you start, you go through puberty
when you get your period.
I think I was like 12.
One.
I had fucking C cups at 14.
My parents were concerned.
Again, I was also five, six at that age.
My family was very concerned.
So they took me to the doctor and they were like, oh,
she needs to stop drinking milk because I was drinking,
like the milk I was drinking, I think it still happens to kids,
but they have so many hormones in them that I grew up way too fast.
They, if I didn't stop drinking milk, they said the hormones in the milk,
I would have been, they said I would have been like six feet tall.
I was, I was growing too fast.
I was, I was in so much pain because I was growing too fast.
Five, 11 at 14, six foot two.
See, okay, you're like, that's fine.
They said, oh, she's going to be either from five, nine to six, four
when they're like estimating my height.
My mom is five, five and my dad is six, four.
And then my mom was just like, oh God.
And then my dad's like, I can teach her to ball
because my dad was a basketball coach.
I can't do basketball.
I fucking suck at basketball.
I preferred, I preferred like football or soccer for sports.
And everybody would always ask like, oh, you play ball.
Oh, you must play ball.
You so to, oh, you're only 14.
You must play ball.
I'm like, no, no, brother.
I don't, I fucking suck.
I can run fast.
And like my dad was, I swear my dad was sort of supportive
because I couldn't play basketball because again,
my dad was like, what was it?
Like a heist, I have to look it up.
Like an amateur league basketball coach.
My dad was good at it too.
Have you juked anyone out in football?
A hundred percent.
I had the tightest fucking turns, bro.
Tight.
Whippin' that shit, bro.
How rich I school interaction.
But it's funny because like, I was like, I was,
I had like a sleeper built.
I had a sleeper built.
I was tall.
I was skinny as fuck.
You're like, oh, she can't be strong.
No.
I'm chucking you across the room.
I'm chucking you across the field.
I'm sending you home crying to your mom
because apparently I'm playing too rough with the kids
because I don't know my own strength.
Listen.
And like, also I was super fucking shy.
But then like, I got this like animalistic
for feralness about me when I would play sports.
And then, and same thing, same thing with fucking jujitsu.
Dudes would be like, because it was a co-ed school.
I couldn't roll.
I didn't roll with a lot of the girls because uh,
well, some of the girls didn't want to roll with me
because I was just, I was just stronger.
Um, but like not, not that you can't submit somebody,
but when you're learning, it's not fair.
Cause then at that point, you don't have the skill
to beat someone stronger than you.
So I would have to roll with the guys
or people have a higher belt.
Just because I would just hold you there.
Like I, I was strong enough, especially my fucking legs.
I would just hold you there and just let you squirm,
squeeze you between my legs.
You try to get out, but I'm going to comeore you
or a more economy you.
I'm, I'm sorry.
You know, you're in my guard.
I could still do that if you're in my guard.
For free?
I sound like I'm really fucking humble bragging though.
I'm scared the pegging might be real.
Um, maybe when we get fans late, I'll be loud.
Cause people keep asking me, when are you gonna get a strap?
And we just, do you want me to sit there
like a fucking, how some dudes do it?
How some dudes send, take pics and just be like,
you like what you see.
Do you like this angle?
Do you like this?
And I'm like, you want me to take pictures like that?
What do you want me to do?
Please test these moves on us.
I beg of you.
I'm sorry.
Not that I don't like tributes, but
or I should call them something else.
Stroni said I needed to say code words for things.
I should work on that.
Um, not saying I don't like treats.
The fuck is on my,
the fuck is on my titty?
I'm a fucking zit.
Okay.
Don't touch it.
Um, not that, uh, I don't like like,
like little treats that I get sent, but
I'm like, I compare like the girlies on Twitter
that be posting their pictures
and then the dudes on Twitter
that be posting their pictures.
I'm sorry.
Girls win.
They're a lot more creative with their poses.
Dudes just stand.
I wish I could demonstrate.
I also want to, um, I saw that
Cottontail VA to the thing where, um,
she like crushed a milk jug between your thighs.
I definitely want to do that for like a milestone.
Maybe when we hit 10 K, it's funny.
Like, I just want to say like,
literally my goal, one of the goals I put in my debut
was hit 10 K subscribers and we're already at six K
and I'm just like, what the fuck?
I'm like, I expected to be at like 800 by now.
She's a watermelon too.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Man, I need to work out again.
I've been, I've been, since I've been laid up at home,
being depressed.
I haven't, I haven't worked out.
I need to, I need to do stretches.
I need to get ready.
I don't look at pics of dude on Twitter.
Uh, neither do I, but the Twitter algorithm just fucking happens
and shit just shows up.
So
he's hit 10 K right now.
But yeah, I just, I'm just very thankful for the amount of growth
that we've had as a company.
It just boggles my mind to be honest.
I didn't, not that I didn't believe that we could do it.
I just didn't think just because of like negativity and coverage
and all that stuff.
I just didn't think people would enjoy us as much as they do
and I'm so happy.
How would you describe your peak build?
Like Elden Ring?
No, like on a partner or on myself?
Because for me, I don't really care what you look like.
I'm like, I would just want you to be healthy and be really funny.
And then for myself, I would like B cup titties.
And I would like to shrink my tummy a bit.
That is it.
Although if I could, I would look like lean beef patty,
but my body type just won't allow that.
Because like genetically, because like guys are like, oh, flat stomachs.
Oh, like I'm like, I'm, I'm skinny, average size.
But because of my genetics and being a woman, uh, people are like,
you're fat because I have a little protective pouch of fat around my uterus.
If I were to have a child, um, even my mom, who at my age was like 99 pounds,
if not less than little, no, she was definitely like a hundred pounds
and like five, five, she was sure as fuck and skinny as a fucking rail.
She also didn't have a flat stomach because just genetically, she just had a little bump.
Child makes it better.
That's my, I agree with you.
I agree.
Squish is good.
A little bit more hold on to, you know what I'm saying?
Not that I don't enjoy like a skinnier build though.
Like I, I honestly, I love the human form so much.
Becoming so many shapes and sizes.
It's gorgeous.
I love it.
Men and women appreciation in this house.
Okay.
You're cute.
You're gorgeous.
You're beautiful.
Let me kiss you.
I was going to say something else, but I can't say that.
It doesn't even look bad based on your photos.
Looks pretty.
I can't, I know that you're like trying to compliment me, but that sounds weird.
Yours don't even look that bad.
I don't care how people think about my body type either way.
One, because I'm a Vtuber, you're barely going to see it.
That was just for the monetization milestone.
I'm not cosplaying myself constantly.
I'm sorry if you thought that you're going to see me
blasting my, my kuchi-hu-ha on fans.
Lee, that's not going to happen.
No, it's only to use straight homeboy.
I'm, you're going to, you're going to get the model.
Oh hi, Rena.
I mean, it's all right.
Like it could be better.
Like, I'm sorry.
You're not going to see any real life content from me.
I don't know about the other girls, but not from me.
I'm here to make ASMR.
I'm here to voice act.
I'm here to be, you know, your girly pop or something.
Don't only get to your head.
I'm here to be your mistress.
You don't make demands of madam.
You get little treats now and then.
I think anyone's complaining.
Yeah.
Because some people are like, oh, they're going to be like,
the Emma G girls.
No, we're, no, at least I'm not fucking doing that.
It's hot though, but I'm sorry.
And I'm not fucking my gen mates in an off collab.
How does this weird business practice?
I'm not a porn star.
But what girls, there are other,
there are Japanese AVTuber agencies that do that sort of content.
And I don't knock them for it.
I think it's fucking amazing that you get essentially
as a porn star VTuber.
Like that's fucking sick.
But yeah, ruined.
I'm going to have, guys,
should I have a watermelon blueberry
or the mystery color airhead?
I also need to get a drink.
Quite thirsty.
Have you finished the main story for inscription yet?
Bro, I didn't even start playing the game yet.
We're just talking.
I've been in inscription like three times.
I just haven't done them on stream mystery.
Mystery.
Okay, we sing mystery.
I'll do mystery, then I'll do watermelon
because people are saying watermelon.
Johnny's asking how long I'm streaming.
Probably too late.
Why does she message me?
Hold on, okay, discord.
Oh my God, a giant fucking.
What is that?
What is that fucking bug?
I need to take a picture.
Holy shit.
What is this?
Mind you, I know my bugs.
I've never seen this before in my life.
What are you?
Hello?
Okay, it looks like it has the body of a wasp.
It was the head of an ant.
It's very thin and narrow.
I thought it was like a locus or something,
but it's not a cricket.
The legs are too small.
What the fuck?
I need to piss.
I just choked on this fucking thing.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'll respond to the letter.
Um, the girl leaves for my collab tomorrow,
like, hey, thumbnail.
So I'll post something more later.
Hi, Sheeby.
Mom, I'd like to redirect here.
You think you'd be...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
100%.
I'm gonna be up for a couple hours.
I gotta piss.
Sorry, I'm gonna keep saying that until I go.
Hmm.
The watermelon's good.
It might be a persic, wa.
I don't know, it's so huge.
It's probably...
I'm trying to think of a comparison.
Using my pill bottle.
It's like, I have a 15 pro phone.
It's like half the size...
It's like, lengthwise, it's half the size of my phone.
But it's super...
I've never seen this butt before.
It's staring at me.
It's literally looking at me.
I know it's looking at me.
What the fuck are you, bro?
I need to identify you.
I can't see his waist.
What are you doing, bitch?
Stop staring at me.
Staring at me because I'm not wearing pants.
Remember, Plee comes from the club door.
Let him inside?
Okay, yeah.
It has six legs, two long antennae, long narrow body, reddish,
reddish-orange, ants moving like head,
but doesn't have the jaws of an ant.
It's like that.
The head shape of the eyes.
It looks like it's divided in three sections.
You have the head, the middle section, and the body.
But it's very little distinction between the main body
and the latter part of the body.
It literally just turned its head to look at me.
It's literally looking at me.
Why do you have so much self-awareness, bro?
Stop.
By the way, should we do a play on the weekends?
Quick ball.
I'm doing the UNO club.
I might do a gorilla debating.
I do realize I need to probably take breaks, though,
like have a dig off.
Do you need me to cover her cleavage?
Oh, yes.
Wait, did mommy read?
Or is she just asking for like 20 minutes or not?
But yeah.
I need to do the corals, please.
Orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange.
Say what I really want.
I'm sorry.
Boats.
Back.
Like a wasp.
This literally looks like none of them.
It looks like a wasp, but it isn't.
This again, I'm sorry.
I'm a very curious person.
This is going to bother me if I don't figure out
what the fuck this bug is.
I like bugs.
This one's giving me weird vibes.
He just shat on my window.
Maybe he's a shit.
Maybe in room.
Don't want to tell me who he is.
Oh, he just flew away.
Fuck.
No, I need to study you.
Maybe we're new form of insects.
What the hell?
Okay.
Elden ring.
Oh, that's right.
It released today.
I have to mute Elden Ring then on my
excuse me, on my stream.
I mean, on my Twitter.
Don't want any spoilers.
Let me take a photo and ask AI.
I took a photo.
I was going to show it to you guys,
but it would expose where I actually know.
So, I zoom in, hit top, crop that, and crop, crop, crop it, crop these.
Fucking load.
69.
Nice.
I'll post it later.
Wait, can I?
Look up bug.
Up here.
That one just like that.
Again this one.
Born-tales.
Yes.
A little bit lighter in this whole here.
lighter in the color. It's in body shape.
I like knowing things.
If you don't f**king like that I talk, then go home.
You don't have to watch. You can click off to show off your computer and walk away bro.
I feel like yapping. I feel like I haven't yapped. I don't know why it feels like I haven't streamed when I streamed recently.
I'm eating my last airhead.
They're mini airheads.
I'm yapping some voices in my head.
Yapping my heart's potential.
I've been craving airheads lately so I got some.
Usually I'm a gummy worm kind of gal, but they didn't have any of them.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm going on vacation. I'm going to leave you with this sh**.
Thank you for becoming a member brother.
I remember watching a video of somebody freeze drying those giant snake ones.
I got some beef jerky. I also have some bueno.
Oh wait, I guess I ate the bueno and I didn't remember. So that's a lie.
I just have beef jerky next to me.
You don't have a Twitter account?
We give you so many f**king freebies on there.
Because that's like us actually doing stuff.
Whereas in the ASMR, well I don't know. Some of us might be actually doing stuff.
But mostly the ASMR is just us recording the script.
That's pure unfiltered real amateur audio on Twitter.
It's not as she be streaming until she's an hour plus and so is the start of the game.
Stop it! Stop!
Stop complaining! Stop pointing it out!
How do you learn how to growl?
Whatever you do, don't eat the famous gamer gummy control.
What is that? Almost said two hours. Now I'm going to yap for two hours.
Well, I'm going to pee first.
So, beer be.
Did my cat hit a key?
Because I heard her walking on my keyboard
Like does my model look okay?
I was like watch if she watch if she like unmuted me
You guys just hear me
Wash my hands
No, I
Need you to wash before me
The cat was typing gamer words. Yeah, Raina would do that. I still didn't get a drink
Do that right now
Do you want me to drink seltzer water or a ginger ale? Either way, either one of them might be worth it
I just want to eat actually my friends
I'm drinking some ale lads
It's a real right fucking ale
Yo, we'll play some inscription here
You know where we're trying to do Butcher's voice for the boys
Oh
Fucking stepping in litter you fucking cats. I sweep it doesn't matter
Hmm
Raina you want some of this shit? Raina you want to hit? Yeah, just need
Like
Sweet partner has a show. It's it's okay. I like it. I
Hope they introduce some of the Gen B characters because I'm actually I'm curious what they're up to
I'm on episode three isn't there only three episodes out where the fuck did my oh
Sage is interested so far. Yeah, your character is interesting. I'm wondering
Like what her ulterior motives are
To be honest
It's like she definitely has one. I'm also cracking the fuck up. Wait. No, I can't say that I
Don't want to spoil for anybody
There's a character who talks when they're not supposed to and that character cracks me up
Because I'm wondering who they are
I
Leave attachment humanity. Yeah, so something like she's like she's bored and wants to do something
She's just on a whole other plane of existence
How's the sauna I fucking laugh so hard at the sauna because I had just read the tweet someone tweeted at me saying
I can't wait for you to enjoy the sauna scene and then I saw like I immediately looked up
And then it was the door from the sauna
I'm like, whoa, it's gonna be like hero gasm and then the fucking it's fucking nasty. I'm like, oh
What the hell?
Like it was like around the mouth it was just gross and you got the oh
brother
And actually I didn't really care. I thought it was gonna be worse. I was just like, all right
But I like it was like when they pulled away and they showed that I was like
Wash wash yourself
Do I need to install
Okay
Gonna watch the thingy let me copy this
What's that brother, what's that?
Mmm, but uh the the gore is pretty good this season. Um, I
Like the gore I
Laugh because Ryan's voice cracks every like five minutes, but that's because he's an actual kid whose voice cracks
See me turn off my BGM
Oh
It's mommy
What is this voice that I'm doing I didn't even know I could do that
Welcome in the raiders we are about to live I've been talking for two hours about nothing in particular
But um, yeah, we just hanging out. Uh, we're gonna we're gonna play some inscription
I got crowd control
I should be I mean kermit
I'm gonna play some crowd control
Let me move myself over here
I need to shrink a bit
There we are. Hello
Uh, don't mind the cover up. Uh, my titties too strong
You got a nerf on
Uh, what are you gonna do?
Yeah, I gotta switch
We're not playing fall guys. I hear
We're also playing with crowd control
So get in here bitches
fucking
I don't know how crowd control is gonna work with this
So we'll see
I need to put my headphones on
I'm waiting for the game to show up
Come on
Come on Gabe. Oh, sorry. It's not cut. What come on game capture
I believe in you game capture
Oh, hey a patreon audio just dropped. Oh wait, is it mine?
Is it mine?
Come on
I wasn't trying it's just like I tried to stop the burp and that's why it sounded worse than what it was
Wow guys, I put it out new audios every Thursday. So check them out. Yeah
Okay, I'm liking that voice
Little miss pity
Um
Yeah, that one that one's a banger. Yep
That one's good. Uh, should I should I should we take a break for like 15 minutes so you guys can
Give yourself a little treat or
Yeah, oh, oh, uh, yes, uh, please uh subscribe to my patreon for only five bucks a month
You can get amazing smr audios
You can't see but i'm putting my thumbs up
Yes
Okay, this is i'm on a fucking show up. No, I don't want crowd control
I don't know if I do
Am I gonna have to do a different type of capture because that's gonna be annoying
I did pin it with the fuck are you talking about it's there
Everyone she did pin it she did
You do 45 seconds. You're not even gonna enjoy the audio. I'm just gonna be like hey
In turn and then you're just gonna be like
That just fucking disintegrate
Holy shit, uh, I've never played
Casey's mod
Has got it going on. Please show up motherfucker
I have to refresh this don't I
Okay
Please
Challenge walked
Why do I have to pick one of these can I just do normal? Oh, oh, okay
I see I see I'm sorry. You guys can't see what I'm looking at. I have to do a full screen
Capture which is stupid. Yes. I know the screen is black
I've been trying to fix it for five seconds for five fucking minutes
Um capture specific window. Let me just restart it. I don't know why
It's
I didn't I didn't um start the session either. So that's why you guys can't do anything yet
It's not recognizing the game as a game. It doesn't even show up as a window, which is weird
Oh
No, there we go. What the fuck? I don't know why I wasn't showing up. I didn't change anything
Should I uh
Let me start the session
Cool cool cool. You guys can do shit now. Let me turn on my headphones
Where the fuck is my headphones broken?
There we go
We're just gonna do a regular run
Challenge point requirement for challenge levels not met you will not advance to a higher challenge level or lock stuff
You pass this run. That's fine. I just want to do normal run and then we'll do challenge levels
It was ready for just challenging. I don't have my headphones on because I don't like wearing my headphones unless I need them
Because they hurt my ears. Any headphones are my ears. Oh the ear ones
Oh fuck me, bro
Oh, this stote looks different
It's giving me it's popping up that I like beat everything in the original game. Um
Yeah
Interesting
Is it gonna stop all right
Alrighty, oh cute. Is it too loud?
No headphone this this stote looks different. It's a gross starting deck. Yes. Yes, it is. I got the hook. I got pliers
Squirrel
Um
Yeah, so we're gonna play some card game. We're gonna predict this Casey's mod
Uh, Casey's mod is a longer version of the first phase of uh, inscription
Um, let me turn this down. Actually, I think it's a bit too loud
Nope, that's discord. I didn't mean to open that
Yeah first and best phase although I liked uh the robots phase too
All right, what voice would you like?
The
This fucking bitch to have ever get what they call her. I don't know. I always thought it was a her
I always saw her as like a really butch lesbian
It's a flat top romance
hag voice
There was a bit too long. I do agree. It was a bit too long
a smoker voice
remnant
Word what's up mimosa how you doing baby cakes?
Manic in the back of an alley voice like an angry cheeky hag
Deck building hard so I didn't like the second phase. Uh, yeah, I would like I like the second phase because I like the art style
It was harder. I didn't mind the deck building too much
um
Do you mind if I examine those pelts of yours?
Let's start with your hair pelts here. Here's what I can offer
Uh
I like it's she said hair but these are rabbit pelts. Um
Never saw the point in the ring room
Raven eggs skunkerton
That'll turn into a thing
I don't
From whatever call I didn't have any three blood cards in my hand
I'm tempted. I don't I think I already have bones ever get a creature you impairs the combat
I kind of like the corpse maggot
um
I didn't mean to do that. Oh, I can look up. Yeah. I I don't have any three blood. So I'll take the great white
I could have gone the elk fallen, but it's fine
Ring rumors had any uses. Yeah, do not back to me see the mean this game because I'm not that you're back seating
I'm just saying just don't
I don't need your help. Let me play
These pelts are most excellent my thanks
All right, I want to go to I already have my thing full so I'm gonna go to the carver
The bones of the ancient woman creaked and groaned as she approached
With gently shaking hands she placed her offerings before you
Uh, give me the rabbit one
I love manipulating my rabbits
The old woman collected her piece and shuffled off into the dock
She doesn't say anything. So I'm just doing my narrator voice for her
Oh, yeah, I would I spam or Boris really bad
Yes, I know how to play the game beat the game multiple times doesn't mean I'm good at it
But I beat the game multiple times
Why do you fuckers just fucking did
Grand for I can't place it anywhere. What about what did you just do you just nuke my game?
You just
I can't even do anything
Well, the trees will fight for me. I'll grab some squirrels
Perfect
I'll just grab another squirrel and you guys could just fucking do shit
Can't wait
Wow, this is a great run. You guys were just playing. I see this way. This is going
I could see perfect
I'll give me the olive branch before you guys fuck me up
I'll give you the fucking are the fucking bridge. Let's go to the the fucking whatever his name is
You came across a hobbled man standing beside some boulders
You're caught me off guard
Not supposed to see me too further down the road
I don't know what the fucking voice I need like a
I've done a really good voice for him before I can't remember what it is. Oh, let me change my the ambiance
I'm a little bit too white right now
I need a
Can I what the fuck?
What oh
We shrinking it's cold. So we're shrinking. Uh, let's do window
There we are now I'm not flashbang in here
Say wait, no
I gave him like a old timey southern voice and I'm trying to remember what it is. Is he naked behind the brambles? Maybe
I like me a gamble if any I can pick him over that has golden it you can keep it
Uh, which one should I pick guys?
Fall I can't do a fog horn leg horn voice here. Let me start a poll
Boulder I'm folding boulder wrong because I'm tired one two three
Go for it
Yeah, we're playing poker real right
It seems like three is winning up two. Oh, it's two now. Oh three again
Two again
They're neck and neck
I'll wait till it turns to seven nineteen on my clock and I'll pick the pick the one that's in the front
Uh, excuse me that two girls making me burp
Amy is reading me. Wow. Hello Raiders. I think it's I think it's two
What's up, Amy? Hi, baby girl
Well, you guys fucked me up so can I have just give me the beehive
Give me the beehive you wink pick two
How are you doing pin pals? How is how is your stream with your your sweet little sis your little omuto chan?
How is your omuto chan?
I know I'll add you I don't mind that the beehive isn't bad actually
Can't do anything
My sacks full
Oh, how much what should I do for leshy's voice?
I remember before I gave him like a oo oo voice
Mm-hmm
My addiction has been fed another day British like sad old man voice
Everybody nobody's talking because everybody's listening to my audio
They all fucked off. They're like, ah, she's probably just gonna be yapping. I'm gonna go listen to her audio
Brexit Giza
Frisky magician with a neck of orange. What the fuck does that mean?
Jorking it. Yeah, everybody's jorking it
We're dual streaming them
Yeah, right you're busy
You're doing such a good job
Yeah, keep doing it just like that while you listen to me in your other ear
Oh keep going
You know you want to finish the game, of course the amount if I if you could carry us free and you have free
Uh instead perhaps your shop just give for my friend
Oh, it's your fucking right a pack, right? Who is useful?
Was the game too quiet
You
Madam please I'm trying not to fail fail what I didn't put any uh, I didn't say nobody could do anything
All right, what are you fucking?
Why are you doing this?
Can I
Get me a fucking did you guys take some of my cards?
Oh, I have to like oh god, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Don't worry about it
Stop
No
It's fine, it's fine
Do you guys think I lost
I
Not gonna win any game
He's just kind of just like
That's cute
Do any or an elk
I'm gonna get something nice let's get a little something something
I think I muted the game. I did how the fuck did that happen?
What's wrong with me?
You guys just make me so nervous
Uh
Oh wait, no, I didn't get the rabbit head. I got the rabbit bottom that just makes them all hairs
I don't know why I was thinking those were squirrels and that rabbits is what you sacrifice. I don't know what the fuck I'm on
Um
I don't have bugs actually why the beehive
I don't know what this will do
Totally was not paying attention the sound has game. All right, I think I got this one guys
I'm pretty what the fuck was that I'm pretty calm
I guess I'll guess I'll play
Wow, this is great
I was gonna keep drawing fucking squirrels. What is happening?
I
I'm waiting for this thing to like kill the stump. Oh, wow. See, I don't even have to do anything
Wow
Uh, can I stop?
Stop
I can't even fucking play because you fucking bitches. I can't even play a card
This was a bad idea. This was a bad idea
What just happened?
Uh, sure
You turn one of them to a wolf pellet. That's cool. Okay. Sick of
Sick of raise the prices. I should why are you assisting her? Why are you?
Are you the one that's trying to fuck me over?
You want the game to be done that fast?
Easy claps
I'm trying to give you an item but you're full. That's right. Uh, hold on. Yeah, let me fucking change that
I'm raising the price on that shit
All right
Hold on
Ah, I see you
Damaging me
I see you. It's the same person that's doing it too
Whatever spend your money spend your coin
Trying to fuck me over
I'll be the one who wins. Okay. Uh, we're gonna make the damage to a opponent. Fuck you
Oh wait, then I'm just gonna make this 200 and then I'll make this 200 and then I'll make this 100
Ha ha ha ha
I don't know. I didn't really like look through these
Like what they could do
Excuse me
Sounds like cow tipping
Gotta put you in your place you right. Hey, we got a bat
We got a raven egg and we got an alpha. I should have got that raven head
Because then I would have actually no I can get the alpha because then I have the fuck of the wolf head
Oh
I'm gonna keep going to a carver
You came across a small group survivors faces. I'm wondering if I should have just played the normal game
Oh
I might do that actually
Whose help do I want to raise?
I don't know sharks fine
I'm I'm good. No, I didn't mean to
But with the Casey's mod everything goes on lock so like
I want people to see like the madness of the game
Yeah, why you keep giving me shit
Yeah
I'm waiting for you guys to kill me
Depending what you put on the top and the bottom the totem, I think I actually you know what
We're gonna play the the real game
Yeah
We'll play the real game because it's good
so
Two hours and 30 minutes in is the real game folks
In the beginning the world did not know cars
That is until the day the scrap weight
This isn't even the this isn't the beginning. This is not the beginning
This is not the beginning
Why is the second part?
I can't even leave I can't yeah, this is act two hold on
Let me out of here. Why am I a ginger?
Okay, I want a brand new new game
You know what we're just gonna I think because I'm running it from crowd control
Can I help you Fia she's like give me your jerky please mom give me your jerky
It wasn't it doesn't look like there was a chapter select. I don't think so
Um
Let me just use a letterbox and made a funny noise when he ran out of it
Oh
Yes
Sorry, I'm doing stuff
Okay
Hold on
Again, I don't know why
And I don't want to show the game
Please
I don't want you to miss the fun stuff
I
Yes, that's what I had to go back and um there was a chapter select
Um
Please fucking work
Please I just want to
Play inscription with my friends
In harem
Oh my god, I'm literally
Why doesn't this want to fucking capture just fucking captured please fucking capture
I'm going to permit I'm going to permit I'm going to permit
Inscription.exe is not responding fuck me bro
So this because of this fucking thing
Where'd the game go? Oh my god
Maybe I had the right idea with just yapping
I love this game and I really just wanted to show it to everybody and it's not even loading
Okay, I looks like I have to do a fucking display capture which I hate doing
Whoa
What the
Dude that was I wish you guys could see the lightning that was just out my fucking window
That was thunder
And because it happens so fast it's definitely like you know if you know um
You can measure like the distance is like the storm is away
Oh my god
The dark cloud
Oh, yeah, I'm like it has to be like a mile away because I was so fast. It's like a second
If like if lightning hit strikes and then you wait you count the seconds
That's how many miles away the storm is and it was like a second after and then I look on my window
In there the darkest clouds I've ever seen in my fucking life
And my cat freaked out
Um
Baby are you okay?
Hmm
I think it's a scaredy cat so I have I just want to make sure you just let me get some water
That was intense
That was that was crazy what the fuck oh man
So it's something in your vicinity on fire now because oh no no no just because lightning strikes doesn't mean something's gonna be on fire
It just it just flashed
I
The best
Last time I streamed inscription it went perfectly fine, so I don't know why the fuck this is doing this
Stepping on litter
My favorite thing to do
She me must now I'm wondering if I should actually like
Wow those clouds are
moving so fast
Um, it's supposed to like thunder. I think tonight. I thought actually I thought it was supposed to be tomorrow
I'm wondering if it's safe for me to stream at all like streaming during a storm because I don't want to like if there's a power surge or some
shit
A guy in my village got struck by
your village
Anyways got struck by lightning while stood outside his house because he was holding a kitchen knife. You're the window. That's terrifying
No
Wait, what if I do this?
Oh
Okay
I might cut the vod
No, I'm kidding
I'm only gonna play the first phase
The first I'm only playing the first act. I'm not playing the whole game
I
Another challenger
Yeah, no, I'm sorry. I'm overriding. I'm overriding the mandem voice. We're gonna do the lolly voice
Another challenger. It's been ages
Perhaps you have forgotten how this game is played
Allow me to remind you
Freaky uh car game play the squirrel card
Now play your stote
Oh
I didn't catch that
Wolves require two sacrifices. You don't have enough bring the bell to end your turn in commence combat
Your stote stands on the post the number on the bottom left is attack power one
Your stote don't mean one damage. I added it to the scale
It's getting really fucking dark outside
If you win you win if you tip my side all the way down
Like this
My turn
Yes, we just started playing
Okay, a little pookie bear is a Greek
Coach
Stoats annoying as fuck
Your stote stands in the way of my coyote
My coyote dealt two damage to your stote
That means your stote's health is now too less
If a creature's health reaches zero it dies
It's your turn again
You may draw from your deck or you may draw a squirrel
Oh
How dull
Well
Wolves demand two sacrifices
I thought I turned off crowd control
I guess I didn't
How did that even happen?
I closed the fuck I literally closed hold on
Oh, it literally says are you sure I didn't click yes
No, we'll keep it open. We'll keep it open
What is how oh my god
Fear not the beat is to sacrifice but not removed from your deck
Don't break the tutorial guys. It's suffering was real, but you'll see it again
Uh
That was a good game four damage dealt four weights on the scale
You've won this match
They won't all be so easy
Let me recall your story
Oh, yes
You were lost deep in the forest a single path revealed itself
I was making dinner. Why did she turn it off? Uh, I didn't turn it off
I'll repost actually, you know, I don't know if some of you guys still have crowd control open, but I'll repost the link
You guys break the tutorial then you break the tutorial I guess there's nothing I could fucking do about it
Enjoy you fucking hooligans
Oh
Give me the fucking cat give you the cat another creature joins your caravan
Some of the creatures of the forest seemed willing to follow you
You came across an abandoned sack a ball sack if you will
You found a squirrel in a bottle break in case of emergency and have a second
Another useful implement I'll allow you to tip the scales
Three is as much as you can carry all that lightning
You
Guys if I die will you remember me?
Can you hear the thunder
Thunder he the thunder whoa
It's so funny because only like one
Like the storm the cloud is passing in front of my house
my apartment and only
Only one
It's like half I could see the rain, but it's not on my half. It's like a wall
Of water is and I just saw lightning clear as fuck that was cool
I've seen have you ever I've seen green in red lightning before
That was interesting I love thunder
Your narration always has to be doing double tape and it's actually happening. That's a thing. Yeah
You're ambushed while crossing some rough terrain
By a boulder, but it's not a boulder. It's a rock
I get it. Maybe you'll help me take your turn play along for now
You may now see my moves ahead of time
All right, I will sacrifice your care
Or let me just put this show down
Here we go
All right, I can't really fucking do anything else
Mind the ambitious wolf cub it ain't just swiftly
A rock lobster it's it's iraq
I'm just gonna do that boulder just attack
Did you guys give give power to my boulder? I should get turn the game volume down. Okay
That boulder just crushed that little dog that's sad the airborne bat flies over creatures to attack directly
No
My bat flew right over your stote. It is really fucking dark outside
Even darker than how I am in the darkness right now with my spinny little fucking eyes
I don't think I'm gonna squirrel show mine if I fuck you with your fucking mantis
I say what you did
I
Why is this stomp deadly?
Get absolutely fuck you fuck um
I was gonna say something bad
Not what you thought not not what you thought I was gonna say
Wait the boulder got stronger. Yeah, somebody somebody uh
Gave the boulder more power you profound and tripped onwards past the now bloody terrain
No, I wasn't gonna say the gamer word. I was gonna say you fuck wad but swap wad with something else
She'd be based
Whoa, she'd be based
The young wolf cub it grows into a wolf after a single turn. Okay. I don't really need to narrate for that
Uh, I'll take the wolf
I'm usually a great refresher before more elven ring. Oh
Oh, have some of you baby girls listening to my audio
Swamp bog
Oh, it's raining
It's raining though. Oh, hold on. I'm gonna open my I'm gonna open my balcony so you guys can hear
I'm not wearing pants
So
Oh
The day some are right there
I don't know if it's actually getting like
Cheat
Play by my mic if you can't even hear it
I
It's patient ash I
Madam makes you stand in the rain and lightning hits you
I mean if I turn off the audio here, I got you watch this watch this
I
Thank you for the $10 dark up and you're joining the stream
I'm glad you're enjoying it. Thank you for coming. I think I always love it when there's new people and they're just like, uh
Hello
Kind of want a bowl of cereal I'm feeling snacky. It looks snacking
I
Love storms. I love like I usually fall asleep listening to the funder
Yeah, sometimes you like I don't like it when you can tell where the loop part is
That's my fave cereal. Um, my favorite cereal is post-it o's. They used to be quaker o's, but they were bought by post
Those are my favorite
Oh, wait, I muted the game
You know like storms be like windy days interesting
Brain sounds knock me out. You love those too. No way 56 year old taste was it's funny because of my my my meh-meh
My grandmother my grandma loves those and that's why I started eating them because normally I just have Cheerios
Guys, I wish I could show you outside. It's so gorgeous
with a rail
I felt that thunder in my fucking skull. That was crazy
The fuck is wrong. This is a perfect night to watch a horror movie
I never heard of anyone else in my serenity me too. I never hear it
Okay, you stumbled onto some strange. I'm so distracted. I can't focus on the fucking game. I just want to get
You were compelled to choose a worthy sacrifice one will be lost forever. All right, who am I sacrificing?
Uh
Okay
Well, I could
Because it wants me to take that thing because it what it wants me to do the sigil
I don't want to
You know my strat when playing this game was I get the sigil of the cat
Um on the totem
And then the squirrel so every time I killed a squirrel and just returned to my hand and it was fucking awesome
Um, but I'll do
That thank you. What the fuck are you gonna turn into?
Sure
Cat stronger
I gasly spectacle but the soul of the wolf cub now lives in the stout
So
This is a totem fight so all their canine related cards are gonna be flying
He's completely insane you see that right no care for the wolf camera the voice is fucking in pathetic really that's what it was
Only keeps me around to watch me suffer. I usually give him like a like a nerdy voice
And then fucking health
Why do you change the costs on that one? Uh, well have fun
Well, they're they're literally just gonna fly
Oh, but they can't they can't block. Uh, ha ha ha. Uh, ha, ha, ha
Oh, thank you. My narrative voice is amazing. I like doing the soft sultry
British voice
Oh, give me a strange larva. Fuck. Yeah, brother. Oh, uh, okay
Let me uh play something
I guess
My spiff tree have powers
You're one damn a joy from winning
You're one damn joy from winning. You're gonna win. You're one damn joy from winning
Sorry
What the fuck oh
Strong trees
Hey, oh leshy is kind of excited
Yeah, strong trees
Impressive you may yet survive this ordeal
Knock on wood
Okay
Okay, I'll get some flight
Uh, I don't really need to sack her. Well, actually I might make somebody airborne
If that voice is how they're leshy, um, I'm gonna sack my sparrow. I'm gonna make the cat fly. No, I'll make the one of the wolves fly
It should be I'm trying to maintain composure
I'm out composure. You're gonna be composing me. You don't have to be composed
I want you to lose all composure
There's a way out for both of us is somewhere in this file cabin be silent or I will tear you to shreds
Uh
Square road and then we uh square road and then we uh
Are you fucking shitting me right now dude? Oh you fucking can't
Oh you fucking can't
Put a fucking grizzly
Oh wait, is this the one that I'm supposed to lose? I can't remember
I think so
He's power player board
He gets angry if you beat him though for this one because you're not supposed to beat him
You've lost
Using this as a learning opportunity may be the only way to mitigate my disappointment
Get up
I want you to kiss my feet
My little tights
You think you're better than me, don't you you're wrong
I've always been better than you that's why you grovel before my little feet
Huh
Get up from the table
Come lick my toes
Batch me that the candle stick from on top of the barrel beside the door. I'm British now
Give me a smoke you want some smoke then you want some smoke
Oh my god, my cat just scared me. She just brushed against my foot. Jesus Christ
Let me out. Let me out
Bring in here be a good dog
This fucking little hand boy tipped one dollar. No, she spanks you if you lose. Well, she spanks you if you lose. Thank you, boy
Now sit back down good dog
Freaky leashy
Small Victorian child she be cotton ton not cotton bum cotton ton
Let me explain something to you
You can't make me lose
That was one of the two mistakes you can make here is thinking
Now you have some sort of power over me
If you make another I'm going to have to hurt you here. Um
Now where are we?
Uh, all right then
Actually, fuck no, I should have gone to see what was in the pack
Sparrow adder raven. Uh, I want the adder
Just because
I like the sigil
You came across a small group of survivors
Oh
Imagine being surrounded by five hair members
I don't know what I would do
just a
small
offenses girl
I
Wouldn't have any way to protect myself
Priests shrunk them from starvation. They huddled around the campfire
They looked upon the group of creatures and beckoned
Come warm winning your creatures by the fire once said
Warming by the fire that will enhance its power said another
You know just one of the survivors who I've been drool from their mouth. Where was it something else?
Like come
Everybody's so quiet
I'm looking at chat and nobody is fucking talking
Because you fuckers. What are you doing? Please stop. I'm shopping
You're at the moment
He's too busy. All right, let me continue then continue continue. Don't stop. Don't stop
I'm gonna make my cat strong
Because I need to sacrifice it
One of the survivors reached towards me
You're not allowed to touch me dirty piece of trash. I told it
My mother gnashed its teeth
tugging on my skirt
Without a word I pulled it away
and left
I
Listen to your beautiful. Uhu story. It's like I'm focused just to join
The trees seem to close in around you as a chill mist ascended
In the distance you could hear the clinking of metal and stone
As I change you up
and bound you
Stuffing my panties in your mouth
Gagging you
You can't escape
You're mine now
And I will join the pet
Okay
Go on
A figure stood in your back
He was the crossfactor
Stop I want you to stop
No touchy no touchy
I don't know why I have to look at that
Um
You motherfucker you motherfucker fuck your mother motherfucker
I want a gold digger. I ain't saying she a gold digger if she ain't messing with no broke broke
Did I neglect to mention overkill damage?
That's when you're tied up so tightly
Bound back
Brisk burning from the friction of the metal
You start to lie. You can't escape
I don't waste any damage
You create in your neck
And I press my little tiny heel to your throat
Try to breathe now
I
Freaky prospecting
You can't spend easy verses than lunch. Yes, I can
Can't fucking do anything
I hope you didn't think it would be that easy to escape me now
Did you
I'll let this step on your balls next
How does it make you feel knowing that a little girl is stomping on your nuts
There's golden cards
I
Gold I've struck gold
Don't worry about it you just give him a wolf you fucking bitch
You fucking cunts you fucking concier you don't matter
I
Serpent perhaps more deadly than man
They strangle
They choke
Which is what you're experiencing right now as I'm stepping on your throat
The cat's supposed to return from my hand so I don't know what happened with that
All right
Let's fucking go
This cat returns of sacrifice that time I just got molded and that's a good point
Allow me to let your candles once more. I won't be killing you quite yet
You're the first in a while to overcome a boss like me as a reward
I'll let you sniff my cunny
Here I mean your granted opportunity to select a rare card
That's what I said. What are you talking about? I said select a rare card. I said select a rare card
Guys, I don't know what the fuck you thought you heard, but it was incorrect. Choose carefully
I
Gek
I like the Gek because I can just like
A strange law is good too
I
Free monies
Hundred geck's even it's gacky joy
It's gacky joy. It's fine. What are you talking about? What's the matter? It's fine. It's fine
It's fine. Everybody relax
Hmm
The rink smell of rot and mold permeated the human air
Every step forward was answered by some nearby slippers
You tread cautiously into
The wetlands
You know what also is a wetland
I
Haven't seen the my colopis is the mycologist yet. So I fucking hate the bullfrog. Um
But it is good against defense
Or I can make a
Actually, I'll get a river snapper because then I can see the mycologists and put them together
Uh, I can't tell what that's up. Okay. No, that's the
Thing you can use to mix stuff
And that's the actually I would like that. Yeah
Not gynecologist the mycologists are like mycology is study of mushrooms
um
I'm gonna sacrifice the adder and the gack is gonna get it
Anything that touches the gack dies
The study of yes, the study of my
Stop with the fucking first
Oh my god, the fucking Jesus
Bees
Oh god, these furs are actually kind of helping me out
Oh, oh nice fucking try adding a fucking grizzly ha ha ha
So, you know a mushroom expert in the game you fuck Jesus
You can merge together cards with the mycologists
The inviolable beehive when it's attacked you will drop me
A sparrow herbal frog. I'll get the look at the the beehive
Beehive
Was popping brand new web just hopped in
Uh
We'll give it to the wolf
If the wolf gets actually know if the river snapper gets attacked because that's six
So that means you can take six hits so I can at least get six bees
Bees brother
Be confusing chat with this one. Hello and goodbye beehive
Is how is everybody doing is everybody okay? Is everybody doing fine? Oh my
Who keeps doing this I need a check hold on who keeps who keeps doing this
It's the same person
Oh
Oh my god, it's the same person just doing it
Oh my god, wait a second. Can I please what are you doing? I can't just fell from somewhere. I don't even know where
Can you hear him making those noises
He's the reforestation efforts
Who's who's who's nerd who's putting it was like beefing my cards up right now beefing up my furs
Thank you for the grizzly who wears what does the fuck is a spider?
Wait, oh, I don't god
I can't
I never noticed a spider in the game before well looks like I'm just gonna kill with this fur
This is fun
I like this is this is a great game
Don't get ahead of yourself. Okay use that
And
Ha bitch shit
Ha bitch
I might get fucked a little bit. I'll see what the fuck is this
Huh
The hell I didn't even know that card could show up
That's so weird
Uh-oh
Uh, I'm just gonna
Oh cat actually, you know what? Yeah, the cat there
Okay, I'm gonna squirrel that just to block anything. It's fine
We're good. We're good. He's gonna die. That's okay. That's okay. Fresh point
Yeah
Yo, she got the card don't underestimate
How brutal of you
You dealt me more damage than you needed to win
However, in my game such feats are rewarded
I like pain
To be precise a tooth to keep for each extra damage dealt
A trapper may be interested in your spoils
Get clapped freak she
You were stopped along the way by a trapper looking to liquidate his pelts
There was something uncanny about his appearance, but you were quickly distracted by his ways
Care to log out to my pelts
Uh take a pelt for your charge. Holy shit
Okay, uh you wink
See the quality see the quality
I can't do it or
An accent right now. Why is it only saying I can
Wait one two, can I buy this? Oh, I can
You you're leaving already, please consider me pelts. I don't have any more money. Why are you fucking asking me?
Can I please leave
For thanks for your business did you pelt top rate?
Yeah, you just likes to roleplay
The man I showed you of the value of the pelts
They appear to be useless and fine. Oh wait, sorry, but he mentioned because I realized
Unless she's talking right now you can see him when you can't see him
That's when yeah, you know
But he mentioned that the trader further down the path but her boarded you for them
I got burp
No
I kind of want to beef up my yuck
I want to be a hundred yucks
A group of starving survivors stood around the dying campfire
Dying to sniff this
Delicious smore there is room for a creature on the fire
The warmth will enhance its powers
When the survivors are nothing at all they could not stop licking there
Oh
What do you mean? What's the matter? I'm just enhancing my gek. I like my gek. This little guy
See I can just be like gek
Get fucking geeks get fucking geeks get fucking geek. Thank you for not doing 50 000 grand furs
Oh, I don't know why I put them both there
A thousand cats
She cannot be trusted with voicing regular dialogue
She
Be sweet
You encountered a small outpost in the woods tempted by a mysterious woman
It was a trick
Are you guys good boomy the fucking what are you doing dude?
Stop harassing reina. She's old
She's an old woman leave her alone
I
Need a sip
Her appearance wasn't settling but you're a modified but you're offering
Do you mind if I examine those pounds of people know what was the voice I use?
You mind if I examine those pelts of yours?
Let's start with your hair pelts. Here's what I can offer
I can trade you any of these take your time
um
Okay, I have more burbs
Should I get a burb? I think I'm gonna get a burb in case I get a burb totem
Is that a golden pelt magnificence? Oh, I can get another dick
Dick
These pelts are most excellent my thanks
I think there's a clip of me when I was reina and I was just like
Okay, I gotta kill this child. How many times I feel like I have to kill this child
I'm gonna sacrifice this child. We gotta fuck this child because I was referencing that card
And if you weren't like, huh, I don't think we're when they weren't listening
Okay
Okay, let's throw the other gek on there get absolutely fucking gacked bro
I'm gonna I'm a gek strat. We're sweeping with a gek
We're doing the gek deck
I'm gonna get only gecks. We're doing a gek deck
Jelkin or gek. I'm a big gek gamer. You know, I always keep that motherfucking gek on me
Oh
My boss battles are high stakes tests of your aptitude
As for intelligence you seem to be doing well without
I just called you an idiot. He what are you gonna do about it?
Nothing
Because you're a little pathetic whiny bitch
With one flame you'll either overcome them or die
Do you want to die?
I can string you up and pull you apart like one of my favorite dolls
You're not I will let you keep the smoke you want some of the smoke bro. Let's fucking I'm gonna duff you
A
Foul smell invaded your nostrils and caused your throat to see
A hulking man said back
I get maybe maybe duff as a colloquial term
It for my area because when you say like you want the smoke like you want to fight and duff means like you'll beat someone up
Like I'm gonna duff you. I don't know why that comes from
I don't know
I'm getting whiplash from excitement to laughing my ass off
A hulking man sat by a brackish pond with his feet submerged in the dark water
He pulled a hook from a pile of rotting fish and rose to his feet
I'm the angler go fish
I can love the soundtrack for the boss battles
Catch the smoke. Oh my god
Uh, I don't know what you guys did but you froze my game and you did that
I can't select anything
Hey, what the fuck you guys broke my mouse. What the hell?
I
Literally I'm looking at the air I'm getting so many fucking error logs right now
Up you guys have to play for me
I can't do anything you guys have to play for me
How can I I can't pick anything up I can't move my mouse you guys broke the game
I
Can't
I can only do this I can't even continue
I can't move my fucking mouse what is up with that I can't even ring the bell
Well
Gigi wait, why do I why do I have four things on my in my backpack?
Oh
I would love to use something
Stop giving me
It's up. Just guys. Just just
Add one more
Fucking tooth because I can't move stop adding me cards. I can't I can't play the game
I'm waiting you guys will give me a gizly grizzly, but you won't fucking give me a tooth
I
Can't it won't end until I hit the bell. No, it'll end if I get one more tooth. I can't hit the bell
Maybe try one in two of you say to put it in rice. I just look so angry. I'm just fisting
My god, I'm just
Looks like I gotta end the game
I'm really sad
Because we got far and I'm slipping away
I'm fucking hating it here. I'm really sad. I can't hit the bell
Okay, what if I
get
error
Object reference not set at to an instance of an object. Whoa. There are so many error messages in this the log. What the fuck?
please
Please let me use my mouse. What if I do that?
What if I oh no, oh the window froze. Oh the game crashed
Oh
My cat just hissed he's also sad. Oh, you know
Okay, it's fine
It's okay. Don't don't worry about it. Don't
Don't worry about it. Okay
That's okay. It's fine
I
Congratulations, you broke I'm wonder. I don't know which one
Fucking broke it though. Like somebody put something on the other board and then all of a sudden my I couldn't move my mouse
So
You keep looking over it so they they nerf my game
I don't know the game also doesn't want to be captured again
You
Nope, you guys don't get to watch
Oh my god, please
Trying to give her bones before she had them at first. Oh, yeah, I think I think it was the bones
Yeah, that definitely
Yeah, I was definitely the bones then
100%
The bones broke the game. Yeah, because that makes sense to look because the logs said like this object doesn't exist yet or whatever the fuck
um
What if I
Game capture game capture
Game capture game capture game capture game game capture good good good game capture
Please
I wish you could refresh the game capture like you can for other
Things but you can't do it for this one for some reason
If you don't I will let you keep to smoke
Oh my god, I might have to
I don't know why it like in
Intermittently works to capture the game. I don't
I don't get it
Please
You give you give a girl some a bone you you bone a girl
And you break her game. That's what happens. I gotta Riz the game. I don't want to Riz anything. I just want to play
Because
Okay, well
We're just gonna chat
Because that's not working. I don't feel like fucking around with it anymore
Oh, I don't fucking want to talk about my fucking session crowd control. Just let me end it. Jesus
Oh, it's the app time
It's the app time
It's time to yeah, my screen is so fucking bright. I need
God
Let's let's hang out
Do it leshy the company app with you guys. Oh, yeah
Yeah, my leshy voice is too powerful. If I had a model that matched the leshy voice, it would be over for everybody
And um, you want BGM? Yeah, that's a good idea. Um
And it would be the true Cunny Corpo
I don't know if all of us were just
It's still lightning and thundering outside. It's quite nice
She just wanted you to just add extreme have inscription in the background
Yeah, I I didn't rage quit. It was the game's just not
Capturing and I don't know why I don't want to capture my display
So, you know
Model swap for April Fool's will be too powerful. What are you talking about?
um
Oh, you think we should swap models for April Fool's that'd be actually be funny
I think cats are running around. Um
Trying to think of who I would swap with
If I if me and Azura
What
We're to swap with the smaller body type girls in our gen
Who do you think would play who I feel like Azura would be icy and I would be in uh, emmy
Swap of scrawny you think I would swap with icy
Actually, you know what I think I would like to see
Mercy swap with emmy. I think that would be so funny
Um, and then icy swapping with me would be hilarious
And then
Emmy being a
And then straw knee could um
Take uh
Take mercies
Yeah, I think everybody if everyone if we all just like swap models. I think anyone
The dolly doll me lolly fits in me. She's she's a switch
Um
I think I think it would just be funny if anybody got swapped with anyone right now. What are you doing?
Hi, are you trying to hide from boomy? Please don't step on my fucking keyboard
You can oh my god
Lady, what are you doing?
Okay, all right. Oh, you're stepping on my fucking nipple. Thanks
They're all funny as it is. I know I'm saying it would be like funnier as like a joke
not like
for a long term thing
Scottish yandere I would actually that's a good point straw knee playing a yandere character would be very interesting
But whoever takes straw knee needs to do the accent
I think I'm the only one who could do the accent. I'm sorry. You can't see my mouth move because my cat is in front of me
All right, there we go. She moved she swapped shoulders
Um, reina, can you please sit down? Oh, she's rubbing against the microphone. Um, ma'am
Ma'am
Ma'am, please. This is the wendy ma'am. Don't headbutt the mic ma'am
Reina so snuggly as per usual
Um
The cat actually engages with you. Yeah, reina is my fucking I call her my soul cat because she is my she's my baby
I've had her since I was little
Wow
I mean reina is 14. She's an old lady and I love her
She is my my big mama
And um, it'll be funnier for someone to do her accent badly. That's a good point. That would be funnier
uh
I like I think I would only be the one be able to do the bad accent or like an okay accent
I don't know if the other girls can even like attempt a scottish accent or do any accents
Um, I think maybe emmy could because she has a good voice range
Uh, yeah, my cat's interactive me. Uh, I think the only one who's not super snuggly is boomy
We're just but he was like so snuggly as a kitten
And then uh, he's in his like teenage phase where he doesn't eat his mom aka me
So he only he's only really snuggly in the mornings and at night
I don't understand why and when I get out of the shower. He just like wants to be picked up
I don't I think he thinks because I like he thinks I'm dying in the shower and he's like mother
Please hold me
This little climb up on my shoulder. He's so cute. He's just he's a he's a menace
But he's also pussy. It makes no sense. Like he's the biggest dick, but he's scared of everything
Uh, yeah, I have three cats and pray for your furniture. They don't scratch my furniture. They're good
I give them lots of toys to play with um and cat scratchers
um
And yeah, a lot of scratchers
And I I clipped their claws. So they're fine
I I I trimmed their claws. Actually, I need to trim their claws again
Because I I trimmed them like a week ago and
Um, put me almost fucking clawed my leg this morning
You doing the Zeraz model it'll be funny since you have to be actually nice for once
You know, I will say people think I don't do like any k-fabe
Um, but I do
I'm very I'm usually a very very nice person. I'm not I don't bully my chat
Um
If you knew me as Rina, I was usually the one bullied
But I realize I do enjoy bullying my chat and bullying you guys and being mean
Hey
Um
It's bully right. Yeah, I am kind
Listen to my last audio. I'm the most kind person
Letting you even come near me, you know
Yeah, I like I like it
Being
Emmy bullies more
Okay
What is that supposed to mean?
I I have noticed that people like
Compare the girls to each other for some reason in terms of like what their kinks are because like we all
um
Like yeah, we all have like our tags that we we we do that like influence our
Our audios
But like doesn't mean we can't dip into other tags like me right now
Pretending to be you know, cute and funny
And then like amy being yandere because that's what she used to do
or straw knee being like
subbie or whatever the fuck
um, but yeah
It's just we're gonna have we're just we're just gonna have fun and do whatever, you know do whatever
Don't don't pigeonhole us in a box
Uh in the hole pigeonhole, whatever the fuck that means. I don't know. I'm tired
Variety is good for the soul indeed
Straw knee is still so you know, yeah, that's actually true that she is
but like
I have to be honest. I'm kind of frustrated
because um
I like
I feel like
A lot of the girls like some like
some of the girls get to be themselves and
Their fan bases are cool with that like straw knees because I my dream is like to make
to cultivate
A group like straw knees and like really you know dedicated
Reflings and I love like that their relationship and they're like cool with how she is no matter what
but like
Then like when I try to branch out and do something else or one of the other girls do everybody's just like
And I'm like come on man does let me have fun and I'm gonna do it anyways. You can't tell me what the fuck to do
I think it adds a lot more depth to each of you almost like a real person because we are real people. What do you mean almost?
We are real people
Oh
I'm new here. I don't really know
You know, like that's how we are
What do you mean? I don't like I like I like how my harem is
well
I think you guys are very similar to reeflings. I know some of you are reeflings. So like
Yeah
YouTubers or robots confirmed
I think they meant the characters you play
Uh
And I said this earlier
We're not playing characters
straw knee hired us
to be
us
And I think viewers took too much stock into the lore and the characters, which is not
It's a thing in v2 being but it's not a huge part of it. It's just almost like a guideline
for direction
She hired us for our voices and to be ourselves
Feelers AI generated. Yes
But like you don't have to give me reassurance
I appreciate it
Um, I don't want this to seem like a hug boxy thing. Like I say something you guys are like, oh, but you're amazing
Oh, but you're this
Uh, I'm just telling you like I'm just telling you how I feel. That's it. But I still appreciate nonetheless
um
Yeah, reeflings are nice fellas. They're cool guys
Exactly kayfabe is nice, but not if it diminishes the overall experience. Exactly. Ow. I'm just like
hoping myself in the face
It's okay to be you she be
The lore was the catch but you guys keep us. Exactly
Exactly
It's a habit vtuber fans won't you but usually they don't like and all the small vtuber communities. I've been in which is a lot
usually people just
Complain about kayfabe and like why do we even have this nobody cares about lore get rid of the lore
Nobody cares about this animated lore video people worked on uh
And then like I just noticed for our company. It's not like people just really want us to stick to our lore and I'm like
We don't have to
You like me for me and if you don't like me for me, you know, you're entitled to that opinion
You entitled that to to that opinion, uh, baby cakes. You're good. I respect you
You know
Lore's like the costume you wear at a party yourself. That's a good analogy
Yeah, like
Astrony was telling us the other day like she's like all I wanted you guys to do was to like say a funny
Funny line pertaining to your kayfabe every now and then you guys don't have to like actually play someone and I'm like
Okay, and then that's when I was like, okay, I'm not gonna like lean into the kayfabe of like
Being the super huge
jealous
Demanding madam because I'm like I'm pretty okay. I'm okay. I'm fine
Like I'm still growing and learning. I'm still like playing parts of the kayfabe
But I'm just gonna do what I want because I'm just having fun
And I I came here to be a content creator and make cool asmr content
Um naughty and otherwise and yeah, I didn't and I know
I'm tired now. Actually. I'm just got really easy
Excuse me. Congrats on 6k. Thank you
Um
But anyways, I don't want to like perpetuate that conversation. I think I got it
I think you guys get it. What I'm trying to say. Um
But yeah
Uh
Rainy epitime
I'm thinking of like what
I'm just about games to play but like I feel like watching a horror movie, but I don't know what horror movie to want
Oh, we gotta watch along next week for our first membership stream. We're gonna watch the master of disguise. I'm very excited. Um
I think I have a collab next week
Yeah, we do with another agency, which is gonna be cool. Um
I'm a bitch with horror really are they core movies? Um
Why is someone's name just diddy your name is fucking quantum physics official
What the fuck is your name dude? Don't hate on don't hate on diddy. You have no right
It's a good bad movie what freaking nda's a stream. No
What movie
I like paranormal hammer, but I like paranormal horror
I can't watch paranormal horror though like too often or I'll like I
Will start to get really paranoid and think that there's a monster in my house
I can't believe she is a diddy supporter not like that
Not like that
Um
Listen, I have the most creative name here. Isn't that just like your normal name? I'm sorry dude
You also sound like you have a really bad porn star name
I always like to know like what is the reason behind people's names
Like why did you come up with that? Explain to me right now why you came up with your name
I'm sheebie. I didn't pick my name, but it comes from sheebie shabari
What and then cotton bump because I'm a cotton tail rabbit girl
But I couldn't be cotton tail because there's already a cotton tail
And that would be stupid
I
Don't think I got my monster fucker license. I I've said this before I actually have I said this before
Um, when I'm scared of something I usually sexualize it
So if it's like the babadook, I'm like, oh look give me the babadook pussy, you know
I thought I should just change it from something other
On other name by name, but you picked like the most boring one
Some of you guys like tiger festivals nugget
Blue sky like what are these names guys?
Well yours desu, that's that's funny. That's a funny joke. I like that. That's a good one
Babadick
Wow rude. Well, you know, I like nuggets. I take that back nugget
Named after Johanna the false pope interesting. I thought you were just talking about fucking yo-yos
Dragon god of chaos. You have the most
Chewney fucking name
What do you mean you didn't think about your name you clearly thought about your name because you have a long ass name
Mine is just a lily abbreviation for pokemon than my name. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, that's yeah, that's right
Lapjack doctor, excuse me. I mean
dark the
Randomness t news. Yeah. Oh, yeah, mine was like mistress muffin when I was younger. So I came maybe I should shut the fuck up
Can't believe she be to use nameshaming us
Delusion
Sorry, I'm just I'm sorry you guys have funny names
Yeah, a lot of people usually have names from like a long time ago from when they were kids and they're just like
I can't even remember the reason like I've had the same. No, actually, no, I can't say that
I don't want people to hack my account
That's the same password for
Um
I literally like care about me use your names like came up with 10 years ago
Okay
Polly paladin
Paul oh, I thought you were like Loki Polly like you were like polyamorous or something
Are you a palsy?
I'm sorry, can you take my headphones off? Oh you said bgm and I never turned it back on I like muted
All 56 years the same password. Yes
I
Named after pop
What the fuck
I really you also have a fucking tuning ass name with gaming katsune
In the near lover of femtum. So I can't really fucking say anything about that
How's the gamer dent coming along? I also I don't wear my headphones on properly
Like when they start to hurt my ears, I usually keep one headphone on and one off
So I would have like a side dent
How to ease my name ruin desolation
You're just like an angsty teen like you're the person who like writes a manifesto, you know
That's what your name reminds me of
Oh
Slanted then pick my name when I was 10. It's fucking awesome. You're literally just a robot though
I write your usernames
Rockstar and you spelt it like you're on my space so you can't talk either. Don't give me the lmao
No
Write my name on a scale of one to ten. I won't
Chibi's in a roasting mood
I also did it because I had a pic of sky with clouds. That's so boring. You're named something original
Uh, you get a chuckle out of me though. That's it though something or that's that's what somebody does to try to be fucking quirky
Be like, oh, I can't think of anything original so I guess I'll put something original
You're like the annoying manic pixie dream girl
Yep, that's you
Chibi's just by checking everyone's names. Don't think you're safe miss morgan
The morgan I'm assuming might be from
mythology
Or from that one video game that I can't remember the name of the lady with the bat wings on her back
Or morgan, yeah, I'm pretty sure that's like from like king Arthur
Darkstalkers. Yeah boring boring name. You just put miss morgan boring
First part is from I can't even read your fucking name run start
I hated having names after the usernames
So
Irish goddess of death and fate
Okay
Maybe she's just named morgan. I don't care
I'm bullying everybody
She'd be really being really nice in the last song tech ninja underscore 420
You have are you like you have a
I'm so frustrated with your name because you're like 420 and smoke
I am a tech ninja. You're just a bro in your mom's basement. That's smokes. We and you know a little bit about tech
And you're in the it
destroyed
Get out of my face rpg. Enjoyer. You just enjoy rpgs. You couldn't think of anything special
Bond enjoyer, that's because you like me
You made a whole ass account because you're too scared to go on your main and like me. It's whatever. I get it pussy
My body is Reggie. I'm not I don't have anything to say about that one because it's funny
Mr. Black silence
Uh
As a black I'ma stay silent. How about that?
Raz nuts
Raz on these fucking nuts, bro
Maybe accepted being the side chick. I don't accept being the side chick
Is I'm just saying you know people are pussies
They have to make a whole ass alt account because they don't want to you know
Oh, I don't want to hurt my oh, she's feelings. She'll stalk me in my DMs if she sees I'm not in her chat
I always get that I'm not even black. I'm Mexican white. Why the fuck would you pick that as your name?
You cultural appropriating bitch, and I'm kidding. I don't really care
Get devoted to the bonuses. No offense, but what? I mean no offense
No offense, what?
This is my maid now, huh? I'm your maid home. I get it. Latino represent
Are Mexicans part of Latin America?
Wait
That was a dumb question. I don't know why I said that. Oh my god. I was
Don't worry about it
And though I was I was thinking of a literally another country
When I said that
You smoked what now?
Our NSFW counts the call. Oh, no, that's kind of fun
I
Super memory banks. I know Mexico is part of Latin America. I I was thinking of something in the Caribbean for some reason
America moment
Intellectual prowess on this person is insane. Thank you. Thank you very much
Um
It's okay. Everybody has shit names
Uh, and you guys have shit reasons for them. It's fine though
I still love you. I still accept you as you are a piece of trash
Mwah
My foot is falling asleep because I'm sitting on my booty cheek weird
I don't know who's by any other name
My name is awesome. Keep lying to yourself, bud
Keep lying to yourself, everybody. My my name's
Stroudy name me
I'll tell you I'll I think I told her this too. I saw all the name everybody's names and I was like, what the hell?
I was like, Stroudy, what are these names?
How do these names remember you? I'm like, I see snow paws
You're gonna be literal
Don't even get me started on Karambit
Don't even get me started in Karambit because when when mercy was Karam Karam before
She was mercy. I was like, I couldn't
My cat's food is going off
I couldn't keep it together. Okay
Her nameless was something else. So I see yeah, she just made everything so literal
Joystick isn't any better. I hope you get a really fucking neat girl
I want to I want a neat girl who never leaves her house for gen two
Here it sounds like csgo name. Yeah, because of what it's a karambit's a knife
But it didn't make sense for mercy to be called karambita
Because she was scissors
I'll never forget you making fun of me. She be a really your name is tiger festivals
I don't even know what that means. You're having a festival about tigers
Huh
She be trying to groom gen two already
Bro
I'm about to know hold on. I shouldn't say that. I don't want need you need you sisters to call me
Thank you. Harcon prints of nexus four dollars and 20 cents
Ignore her chat. She's just mad that we have such an epic names
Ignore her chat. She's a smab. We have such epic names. Thank you for the
$4 and 20 cents
um
Fuck you though
I'm always right
420 strikes again
Down the south they have festivals for vegetables a tiger festival sounds cool. Oh
Why not the slime girl? Uh, um, so what I was gonna say is uh
The girls will be heavily groomed by me. Uh, there'll be actually harem members
because uh, I got a lot of
Female fans. I think I have the most female fans out of all the my gen mates
So, um, I'm grooming them. I'm handpicking them and no, I'm kidding. That's not true
That'd be so fucked
No
You think either what power do you think I have that's trying to be like, you know what she be
You can pick everybody
Do you know the percentage of girls here? Um, I haven't checked the analytic in a while, but it did go up
It used to be one percent and now it's three percent. I'm trying to get the girlies on my side
Try to become the next rants, right? And that's actually one of my favorite of
animase
Bbl she but what what the fuck does that mean go ham she I'm the I'm the shadow ceo
I'm the I'm the actual in fact. I'm dt. I don't know
Um
I'm I'm the manager
I quit my job because I'm like, oh, I gotta handle all these girls
I gotta I gotta wrangle them all and wrangle myself at the same time
It's difficult, you know
It's difficult to wrangle
Look at me. Look at me. Look at me. I am the manager now
Gift don't think you get to escape because I didn't point at your name. Your name is weird as fuck too. You sound like a khajiit
Shout out to women my second favorite gender
Oh, he gay. Okay, I get you. I get you bro. What's fine
You progressive here
I love the gaze the haze and the vase
I don't know what a fucker. Hey would be
Um, the shabari keeps her contains. Oh
Yeah, the the shabari, uh, I'm gonna inject some fake to some no no some cannon lore
Uh, if my shabari come off, I just become
a raging
racist no
One of my I'm over tired. I just become a so based
I can't be held back
Uh
No, it's not good. It's not good. She you can't say that
You're right
Fun fact she besides she'll be covered
I'm really it's funny because I'm like the one of the most like
um
Sorry that lightning was insane. It would flash like five times. It was like daylight outside for a second. Um
What is that what happened when you tried changing your listen, I'm still mad at myself about that
Because I shouldn't have done it on screen because I should have known I would have had an accidental fucking blackface moment. Um
If you don't know I'm brown by the way, I'm I'm a tan human being I am mixed. I am biracial
I am uh polish and I am portuguese and I am french and scottish
And I'm also Haitian
Uh, but yes, and I'm also a bunch of other fucking things. Um
It was curse her racism needs to be it's no it's funny. No what I was gonna say is that um you
No, I'm um portuguese from portugal
Azores um missable wad
I'm a very mixed bag. I thought this was a mixed hag and I liked that
Part native american. I'm actually not native american at all. I thought I was
Because you know, there's always like someone in your family when you're american that claims that you're that you're native
They're like, oh, yeah, like we're like one eighth Cherokee
And so when I did my like 23 and me
Ancestry test, I'm like, oh, I wonder if I'm native and there's like nothing there about being native and I'm like
My grandma fucking lied to me. They also said that we were italian too. I'm not italian
Although it's funny because my mom looks very italian
Italian, I don't know. I'm saying it like that
I am part native american indian. I mean, oh you are. Why would you call it native american indian then?
Why don't you just say you're a native american?
Or an indigenous person
You don't fucking say indian
I don't know if you remember the other portion of that meme as uh with norman osborne as a different color
Um
Uh
Sheeby speaks that gabagoo
100% french here from like two villages
Shout out to the colonizer then sheeby. Thanks mom. Whoo
My dad it's okay. My dad's my dad's country where the was the first country to become independent from slavery. Let's go. Whoo
um
but
No, like i'm a very it's it's so funny because on the internet
I feel like i've been so corrupted
Because i'm very
Like and I don't care if you fucking hate me for saying this. Um, I'm very lgbtq friendly. I'm very progressive
I'm very much a liberal friend
Uh, and I just I don't know why I'm like this online
I'm just an absolute fucking prick online, but you know
I like I like having a little bit flavor
It's like everybody nobody say like I'm not and I'm like I'm generally like
I don't really give a fuck about
uh
Like if somebody says
something
Offensive or ignorant to me. I will put them in their place for their ignorance
But I know I know the context of what's a joke and what's not a joke exactly jokes
And I I enjoy dark humor. Yes
I don't take personal offense
Like sometimes people do just like say things in poor taste like when I was when I was younger. Um
So my hair is curly you can see my beautiful curly hair
I lost tracking because it's dark. Hold on. Let me turn on the light. Um
Okay, turn on the light I have beautiful curly hair
Um, so I usually uh
With my type of curls, I'll put it up in like a
Like a like I'll put in a silk bonnet so that my curls stay nice when I sleep
And um, did I imagine I could love my she be more? Um
And so my friend who's white
Was just like making fun of me
And I'm just sitting there with my with my bonnet on
Um letting my hair dry after showering at her house because we're sleeping over
She's like making fun of me and
I'm like what why why you making fun of my bonnet?
She's like because you look like you should belong on my family's plantation picking my cotton
And I just kind of just stayed at her and I'm like
Like I'm like I could make
A way funnier joke than that
That was just bad
I'm like that was just dumb
Like that's when your white friend gets too fucking comfortable with you and just thinks they could say anything and she apologized afterwards
And I'm just like
Brother it's to me. It's only funny when it's self deprecating humor
Like um
No shot someone is that oh
Are you kidding me bro?
Oh, please
Oh, please there's uh when you're um
When you're a mixed kid, uh
Again, you're too white for the black kids. You're too black for the white kids
And so
When you're too black for the white kids, they'll make they'll think it's okay to make jokes like that
And I just I don't really give a shit because it's one. I just just don't give a reaction
And I don't care. Um, and then when it's black kids making fun of you for being like too white
Um, they'll do the same thing and so
They'll just say like, uh
What did that fucking say? I think they like I remember these black kids said something about my mom
Being like a snow bunny
And I just looked at them like
I cool anyways moving on
Um
And then like it's funny
It's only funny to me when like you make fun of yourself or you make fun of your own race
And that's why like I'll watch comedians who do that
um
Then it's funny to me, but like when it's someone who's just like, haha
Your gamer word and I'm just like, okay
Was that was supposed to be like come on. You could have said that in a better way like, you know
Your racism from all sides and no, it's not racism. It's just ignorance
like there's
I haven't experienced like real racism in like a very long time. I'll be honest with you. Um
It's usually people just like trolling and like just wanting to get a rise out of me
Which I don't really think they're necessarily racist. They're just like just kind of be a stupid, you know
um
Yeah, the last time I had someone like be legit racist was when the story I told before
Or someone called me the gamer word when I wouldn't give them their
Their pickup order because it was or it was canceled for some reason. Um
And then before that I had this European woman
um
Definitely talked to me like, you know how sometimes like older
folks
speak to like
Darker skinned folks a certain way. They'll be like, hey boy get over here
So she spoke to me like that. I was like, I don't
Okay, she called me she called me girl. She's like girl and she had like a very thick accent
um condescending
Kind of like talk slow like I didn't know how to speak English
And I'm like, I'm from fucking america. I was born here
I was literally fucking born here. You don't have to talk to me like that, dude. I can understand. I can't speak any other language, dude
um
Girl come here. Grab me mine. Give me your finest ways
Um, but again, I don't take it personally because people are just gonna be fucking ignorant and you know, they'll just die off someday
So I don't really give a shit
um
It's just I just think of it in like in hindsight and I just like laugh like when I was super young I was like
Really sensitive like super fucking sensitive and then I started playing csgo and I grew out of that real quick
um
My once got asked if I had a green card and trigger me to kick him out of the store. That's fucked. That's fucked
Pulling over butter. Yeah, I'm like I'm like token
Just kidding though. Uh, yeah the boomers will die off. So, you know, they'll die. We'll be fine
Although I'm getting up an age being 56. It's it's kind of scary
Sorry, drink some water. How you doing right now? Your eye is watering
I don't have a knack at near me or a wipe your little eye
Oh my god
We're already way better than like 30 years ago. Yeah
I'm gonna hit 60s in that ropes break off. Yeah
Means like the finest wine we're getting cougars
Yeah, I'm 56 you guys if you guys don't know I'm 56. I am the oldest vtuber in the vtubing community
Uh for real
56, although I think mom key d follows close behind because she's 40. So, you know
I am 56. I'm just in really good shape. Uh, I work on my figure
Some grand tubers who are the other grand tubers?
You know black don't crack
And also the black of the berry the sweet of the juice just look at Azura
I can't wait for my fucking brown toggle bro
Saying this is a white vtuber is hilarious
Because no, it's actually really funny because if my shit that I say gets clipped out of context and like put somewhere
It'll be so funny because then
I could bait the community so fucking hard and be like and just say like the most out of pocket shit
And then somebody who put me on blasts and be like, I can't believe people in this community are talking like this
Like look at this agency vtuber. He's using these words and then I'm like
Um, imagine the clout pass mode activate you you've activated my race card
Oh
God I am fucking funny as hell
Uh
Although it's funny. I like I definitely need to go outside
Because I'm about to revoke my own card with how light skin I am right now. I'm so pale
It's bad. Um
If I was thinking after the storms pass, I think it's gonna be storming for a little bit
But I'm gonna try to go to the beach. Um, I wanted my days off since I work from home
I I somebody I asked twitter. Oh, what should I tell people I do for my job and somebody said a government agent
So I think I might stick with that. She's funny in a racist. No, I'm not racist
I love all everybody from all walks of life
Trust me, uh, one of my best friend's dad is a very fucking racist person
Uh
It's so I'm not like them at all. So I'm like, that's my when I know if I start talking like him. I know I fucked up
I'm only pretend my 1949 moment. Oh, I told my parents about that scene
In fucking class of 09 my dad was laughing his ass off and my mom looked mortified. It was so fucking funny. Um
But it was it was yeah, I'm not racist. This is something gonna raise
No, I'm just I'm just silly. I'm just I'm a goof. I'm just a dark humor girl. I'm just uh, yeah
It's not racist. If you hit everyone equally. Yeah, I do. I prefer animals. That sounds weird. Um
I prefer, uh, my company of my cats
um
Doing anything fancy for pride month. No, I remember the last time I like actually did something for pride month
I did a really cool, uh, because I used to be a makeup youtuber as well not a makeup youtuber
I tried to do makeup
Videos on youtube and on instagram. I did a really cute like pan flag
Um, eye shadow. It came really nice came really nice
um
Why are we calling her racist?
Because they're silly. Well, me you're in the way. Oh, baby. Come here. Come here. Hi, baby
Why do you smell like my lotion?
You smell like you got into my fucking lotion. What are you? Are you good?
He was like that was high expression on his face
Influencer she be must have been a time. Yeah, you know, I wore many hats when I was
Going into content creation as a southern backman. I can tell you I'm not racist, but has preceded some of those wild shit
um
That reminds me of like that fucking vine
Of that one girl who's like, I'm not racist, but 80 people
But she's fucking loses it why lotion this is a cat
People there's lube and lotion lotion like my body lotion. He probably knocked it over. It's probably fucking exploded all right
My what should I call it? Um
Uh bathroom
He's someone's open hookups and then like he says something that I'm not racist. I will like any color hole
I think my favorite thing people say is this like I have I'm not racist. I have a black friend
I remember I remember somebody
like one of
My uh friends
Like we were in a group. I think we're going to like the movies or something. I don't remember what the fuck we were seeing
But one of them said that they're like I have a black friend and they pointed at me and I'm like, no man
I don't count. I'm only half a black person
Like you need you need to find another one to count as a full
I'm like, no
Need at least two. Mm-hmm
You know two halves must make a hole
and like it's funny because like
I'm like the most americanized
Like I'm not I didn't come from another country like my dad immigrated from Haiti
um
And but like not when he was older like when he was like five. So my dad is very americanized too
and so
people like think I'm like very
like
cultural this or that
And like I can't like I've done my research because I you know, I owe it to myself to learn my culture
But then like I have my white girl moments
For sure for sure
I honestly heard the term racism thrown around the media consumes so much it kind of losses. Yeah, and like I like
I don't feel like like there's a lot of like races, but it's mostly like people that are fucking hateful
And it doesn't it's like different. I don't know. I can't really explain it
I got a half black friend
Bro, I had a friend who's indian trade have asked me since I'm africa. Can I see the
Bro
My civilization he has to recognize you forgot how to speak curl. Yeah, my my my dad is my dad speaks curl, but like
My grandmother says he has like an american accent when he speaks it
Pass is not conferrable
I
Yeah, I honestly I'm telling you class of 09 educated me with the
um
Like white nationalism versus white supremacists and I was like, oh
Okay, they both suck. What cool good to know the difference
Um, but yeah, it was just this is interesting
Why am I talking about this shit bro? Sometimes I'm like I
I can't wait to get
The lia fans because like then I can just be like no holds fucking bar because youtube is so
I hate having to keep cut down my vods when I I'm just talking to you guys
But I probably have to cut this vod down too
Because I just I can't be say so
But it's funny. I swear. I was more fucking say so when I was in india on twitch than I am now
I don't even and I'm in an agency. What the fuck is wrong with me?
Never the cause of it. I have much of an impact
Never asked a woman her age never asked a man so I never asked she'd be to not edit a
That's good
When I get the upload notice I can't go
I think I think you guys are a bad influence. It all started
When I started going on the interwebs when I was first becoming a vtuber
This is some not so savory sites
Fuck you guys corrupt me different fans bring up topics maybe. Oh, yeah, actually. Yeah, that's a that's a pretty good point
Uh, we have a different fan base. I have a different fan base than I did before
Um, that's true
like I know I
I have seen like one or two of my past
Like of rena's fans around but because of the constant I do now a lot of my fans don't watch me
Which is totally fine. I accept it. It sucks, you know, it's sad, but you know, I totally get it. Um
So I think yeah, it's it is a hundred percent a different fan base different questions different
um
Yeah
Fans reflect the streamer that that makes me sound really bad
Maybe we're just too submissive to stop holding from saying controversial stuff
But like is it I'm thinking I'm like, do I really say controversial stuff? I don't
Think like I feel like I don't know. I feel like I'm just real. I don't really think I'm controversial
I find it weird that you're so open about your past life. Um
Yeah, see not really. Um
We're allowed to be open about our past life. It's fine. Um
If I there's nothing against us to talk about it
Strani said that when we debuted we can even just we can we can tell our fans that um
Uh that we are in v alert all I did was post a meme on my
My rena account when I was rena no way. Um
Um
But I didn't really feel the need to I had a small community
I knew they would find me if they wanted to
um, so yeah
Don't have to pretend you didn't exist until the other yeah
Not controversial but edgy
I don't really think I'm edgy
I don't even think I'm based look at fucking emmy emmy's way more base than I am you kidding me
Oh my god, you exist before two weeks ago
She entered one time. I think she changed grew up on it molded by the perversion there whole life. Yeah
I never been I I literally
Yes, like literally six months ago
Actually, no not six months. It'll be a year because I was uh, I was a refling. I was an og refling. So that's a lie. Um
Been on the grind for 56 years things getting too sensitive
So you didn't tell your old community I posted it so like you know the lore
um picture
of like me
Holding queen's hand as she's dying in a hospital bed
Somebody who had figured out who I was
When we uh did our voice reveals edited rena as queen in the bed
Dying of sickness and me as she be holding her hand and it sent me so I just posted that
And like like she's like passing the torch, but like it made perfect sense
It was like rena's passing the torch to she be
You know, I thought it was great
So I'm like so I just posted that and everybody responded with lmao and like they thought I was hilarious
And I shout out to that person who made that fucking meme
I'm dying. Stop be boxing caption. That would have been funny. Um
And yeah, like we're we're allowed to talk about this stuff. I'm very thankful for the fan base I had back then
um
And they knew how much I wanted to be an agency and they believed in me more than than I did
And I thank them for that because I would not be here if it weren't for them
I would have no audience. I had no one to stream to and but they gave me a chance
Um, but yeah, where can I see that meme? Uh, you can't see it because I I nuked
uh
All of my past life stuff. So like you may notice that I
um
Went on an indefinite hiatus as rena
Uh, I'll be honest with you. She's essentially graduated. I just did a definite hiatus because
um
Rina means a lot to me as she represents rena who is my cat
Um, so I and rena is a seimees cat. So I wanted to
I made a character after her because rena is my baby. Um, so that when rena passes on which she is older
She's 14. It will happen eventually. I'm mentally prepared for that. Um, that she lives on
With rena. I actually might just change rena's name to rena
To be honest with you, but I will not be going back to rena. Um
I will be she be I am she be she be is me. I am her
We are each other. Um, some people
Uh, presumed because I made her an indefinite hiatus that like they thought I was gonna go back
And somebody mentioned that um, I had commissioned a lot of stuff like for a whole new fucking
Like asset package and debut thing and model and everything for rena
But then I was hired to be a lure so I can't use it
And so as people saw posts of like my assets being in showcases and they're like, wow
She's just planning on going back bro. I commissioned those back in fucking february chill out
I'm not gonna be rena
She is sleeping. She's good. She's fine
I am here now with you guys. You are my little cotton booty holes my harem
I am she be
And I am here to stay. I'm not going anywhere
Not she be she be. Yeah, I wish I'm doing heart in my hands, but you can't tell my hands look cute today. Um
But yeah
You guys are my little pock champs
The fuck why are you so sweet? Uh, I can be sweet. I told you that
I can be very sweet. I'm a very sweet and kind and caring person. I'm a fucking empathetic person
Um, that's why I cry like a bitch half the time
Because I just get so emotional because I feel so deeply and I love so deeply
Um, vtuber's teaching ideas is like a crazy personality disorder. I'll be honest with you like
That's what I love about being a vtuber is that you have so many possibilities
Um, like I if I wanted to for my 2.0. I could just be like, I'm no longer a rabbit. I'm a slug girl
I'm a slime girl. Um, I'm the slime girl. I wanted gen two
Uh, like when you have the money to do so the support the right artists the assets like you can be who you want
And that's what I love about vtubing. I was so put in a box as a flash streamer. Um, when I was one and as a
It's just so fun to play around as a vtuber
Um, I can be anyone I can I can it's it's just it's honestly great
Slime bunny girl the change you want to see
Thank goodness. I'm here for she be intended to stick around I'll thin down around the tears
So it's like hearing all yeah guys. I'm not I'm not going anywhere like don't worry
I am here
Even if the vealur somehow fell off the face of the fucking earth. I will be here
Uh, I am just like strawney. We are here till the fucking end like don't shoot
So when you're going vr chat, uh, I don't know
I vr chat makes me motion sick
Even with the same model. I've already done some great stuff a fanfic reading stream was incredible. Yeah, exactly
Like that was really fun and I'm doing that next week too
Invest in your oh she so she doesn't have to go anywhere
This is why we need a crying harlot emo. Oh
Damn, I should have I should have come because I just put in a request
For more emotes so
Um, although I don't know if you did know me as rina you
Know that I one of my famous emotes that was used very often by multiple people was my crying emo
So I am I did commission that as she be
My what the fuck is going on emo
Because that that that that's that's always been a funny meme
It's better to invest in oh she rather than crypto. Yeah, that's true. You know what you you know what you're getting you know your returns
Said it before she because she put the shrug model in still watch that'd be fucking funny
Know if any spicy arts still exist
of
Cheebie
Yeah
Yeah, um or rina. I know there is spicy art of rina
Um, I even I commissioned spicy art of rina for one of my previous donathan
That I did for fias medical bills
Um when I was rina and I it's still I again I commissioned that in fucking march and it's not there
So I feel really fucking bad about that
Uh, I wondering if my
The skeb artist goes to me for that which sucks
I'm gonna buy nfts. No bad for the environment
Um
And they're also fucking waste of money. You can't do shit with them
I'm just gonna copy paste your fucking nft
invest in a she be coin
Blind bunny. Yeah, slight money would actually be pretty cool
No, because I'm a element now anatomy kind of as you took me back a little. Yeah, some people like as I've I've I've
Did that with rina too
They're limited to emotes is that a limit only and not your best in the art for it. Um
I think there is like a limit for emotes like on youtube
I again, I'm not I'm not far super familiar with youtube's
YouTube's
With youtube and their policy on how many emotes you can have I
Like so I have like I already have more than the four that you're using
um
Like I I have a crying one. I have some other ones
Uh, and then I got 10 more that
I'm that um
I commissioned
and so
I don't so I'm assuming I can have around like
15 maybe 20. I don't know. Yeah, there's no 17. Yeah
Um
I want to say like 50 ish. Yeah. Oh, okay
Well, where are they? I don't know like I commissioned. Well, oh the ones we I we just commissioned our emotes like more emotes
Um, the other ones. I don't know why they're all not added there. Again. I don't know how youtube works
I don't meant manager set up account. So I don't know. I don't know if I can know
um
You can put bttv on youtube. Oh, okay
Are there any plans for management yourself? I'm making a discord server for you vealer as a whole now that you mentioned emotes and stuff
You can't there's a notification server
Um, just for our
And everybody's safety. We're not gonna have a personal server that we frequent. Um,
I know there's like fan servers and stuff and that's cool and all
Which also the people who run the fan server if you're watching can you please change it to not look like our official
Fucking twitter. I will get notifications if you like my stuff and I think it's our official twitter, but it's not
Um, make it make your own fucking logo. Um
Yeah, just because like we don't need groomer cords
We don't need people getting like feeling like they're being favored or the fuck like Jesus
I don't feel like dealing with that shit. It's so much. You don't need that
Um, I know you guys want to hang out with us, but you can hang out with me right now
I'm talking to you face to face
Anime girl to titties to viewer, you know
I think it's I think it's better this way for everyone. We don't we don't need that. Um, you know, trust me
I would love to be
In a discord with everybody, but and I know I would behave. It's just how some people act
Uh in a discord when there is a
talent in there, um
Sometimes they uh
Because they're in closer proximity to the the talent they
They feel like they're owed something and could like
Spam them harass them blah blah blah blah and like I don't feel like fucking dealing with that
Management doesn't feel like fucking dealing with that. Um
Vibes can really fucking weird. Yeah, like I've seen I've been in
discords where those talents are there
And it's kind of a fucking shit show. So
I think it's better like
Yeah
She doesn't want to talk to us. She hates this. No, no, god, like I would talk to you all the time
Like I literally fucking quit my job so I could be with you more
Like
Come on be for real. Um, I'm tempted to I'm thinking about making um
I've seen other streamers do this where they add their, uh
Actually, maybe that's not the best idea. I'd have to ask management about it
But I've seen people add their schedule as a video and they'll like give updates in that pre chat from time to time
Um, but yeah, because you know, there's there's a there's a line you can't
Like you have to be careful and like have a line you can't cross
Just so people don't get hurt. Like I don't want people to be hurt
Um, like I know I see you was very upset. Um, because somebody hurt her feelings
And I don't want anybody else to feel that way viewer or talent. So
It's sometimes we got to do stuff that protects our mental health
Um, but yeah, like, you know, you see me pop into like preach out a couple times
Um, but yeah, I was thinking about a free chat. I'd have to ask management though. Um, but yeah
The other girls are free to
Reach out like that. Yeah, does she do it like in the video of that day or does she have like an actual thing?
Someone made the girls cry and pop in the trunk
No, yes. No someone. Yeah
I
Keep yeah, well like I'll I'll keep you close like again, like you guys said chart reflect streamer. Um
I know my boundaries. I would tell you guys if you ever I ever thought you guys crossed them
Um
But you guys are very well behaved. I don't feel any sort of way for that
Oh, I mean as a schedule free chat. Oh, okay
Wait, huh
Why didn't
Was I supposed to do that?
Why am I so fucking dumb?
Oh gurra's streaming
Her 3d bird I'm oh guys I'm overlapping gurra. I might have to end stream
Jesus fuck
Wait
Why the oh, I'm like, why did Amy just mention me as I'm talking to her?
She just tagged me because she she blew up on the tweeters
Damn, what the fuck she did blow up on the tweeters
Hey, she caught up to me. Yay. Let's fucking go
I was hoping the girls would fucking catch up to me in the
So awkward having so many people in my fucking old. Um
She'll probably pass me soon enough
Where is it? Where is her?
I can't
Because then I want to see how she set it up so I can replicate it
Just creeping on your account. Amy just creeping on your account
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Amy
It's okay. Just accept it. Amy. Where the fuck is it?
Where is it? Where is it? I don't see that
I don't see the free chat. Oh, I found it
That's cool. Oh schedule and free chat. Oh, and she does it for like three years. Oh, okay
I wonder that'll fell fuck with my chat room though my chat room my um
My my chat on obs
Maybe I don't know cool
Okay. Oh, yeah, I'll do that for next week
Nifty what's today?
Is it Thursday? Yes, it's Thursday. Do I stream tomorrow?
Uh
I forgot what day it was. I don't know where I am half the time
But yeah, I'll do something like that
Who's girl how the fuck do you not know who girl is?
Jesus
That live stream to go live for like a year from now. Yeah, okay
Oh, she be do you think you could take her on a fight if you had to be her ass
Excuse me. I would not harm that shark. Are you kidding me?
I would treat that shark as a princess mostly because I'm scared of hollow fans
I'll give you an activity streaming tomorrow in the collab. Is it tomorrow? Yes
I am in the collab. It's not on my schedule, but I'm there
What if you had to no?
I got the majority of the vtuber rabbit hole last year via indy so I learned to follow away after I'm like it I
It's very interesting to me where people find like
Agencies or indies before they do the big names. It's but I've noticed that happening a lot more often
um
But yeah
I'm valid
Hard girl the sush shark kid. She's not sush. She's a shark
It's the 20th teams. I don't again. I don't remember where I am half the time
Girl is the first vtuber I watched. Um, yeah, the first vtuber I watched was kazuna ai
And then I watched co-amigo, but I never really considered her a vtuber. Um
Let's see. Who else did I watch?
And I watched a little bit of hollow. I would watch polymyth naturally. Um, I watched kiara
And then
I had to stop myself from falling in love with shiwari
Um, listen, I love messy manhara
looking types
If we had a goth chick like that and gen 2
I would die. Um
Let's see. Yeah, and then I and then I just watched a lot of agency vtubers like smaller agencies. So like idol
um
Pixel link and projects like I watch
Yeah
Watched a little bit of vrevery like rana. She was cool. Just sucks because I really fucking graduated
I
Miss isn't that mercy?
No, she's not goth
I don't think mercy doesn't look goth to me. She says I'm thinking. Yeah, no
See me a while just chatting started chatting with you there though. Yeah, I feel that
Which one is your oh sheet? I don't have to tell you
I don't have to tell you any of my oh sheets are for me to know
And I hold them close to my heart
Or not for anybody else
Corony
What can I click?
Dory, gen 2, mercy would be mad. Oh, I thought you said mercy would be mad if that happened. Uh, no, uh, yeah
No, that would be that would oh the power those two would have
Literally my name was my name was originally graveyard for them. Yeah. Oh, yeah, you have fucking runatics. Oh
That's uh
The thorn lines. Yeah, but it's it's nice that you can find those people other places now like they're they're doing okay
so
He's trying to gatekeep. I am gatekeeping. Oh, she
Like why do you guys need to know who my oh she is?
They're not like me at all that's for sure
They're very talented very talented. Um
I would watch we cheaper highlights from time to time and never got into them until you guys debut
Yeah, yeah, I like I love watching me two bird debuts
Quick
But you got like they're not it's not like they're not a popular person like they're very well known
Nova's still fun of you ever again
Feel bad for the you every girls
Hope they bounce back
Can I tell you my oh, yeah, you guys can tell me your oh, she's oh wait, are you gonna say fucking me?
And I'll honestly be a lair is the first group to pull me off a hollow plant
I see some words seems like I missed out on some good time staying there for so long
You know, but it's like it's cool to prevent venture out because like again, I feel like
It's it's a lot more intimate being
In a smaller um agency like chat like you can see you can interact with each other
You probably recognize each other's names. Uh, I can talk to you. I recognize a lot of you
It's a nice small little chat and we're hanging out
She used my kamiyoshi. God damn that just weird like it just doesn't make any sense to me that people like me that much
to call me their kamiyoshi and
I yeah, I don't even know what to say besides thank you because I just never thought
Like being like when I was indian never thought anybody would ever tell me that
Make more 200 rather than 2000. Yeah, I like having small chat
I only remember you because you keep saying you lost your job and then you went to the other girl's chat and said you lost your job
And I was like, why are you telling everybody?
And remember this there's a saying move in silence bro make money moves move in silence
She don't yeah, and I notice you on other girls chats too. Don't you forget
More of a casual vtuber fan and watch the content like and the first thing I enjoy don't really have an oshi
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, like I'm the same way
Except like there's someone just like I watch the most and that's who I call my oshi
He lost a new job each time move in silence like lasagna
Like the gene lasagna
Like the end of lasagna
Yeah, identifying you in maros. Oh
100%
they'll become a loved and respected figure in the industry. That's very sweet and
Honestly, that's the goal. I want
I want to be
I want to have the same
I don't it sounds really fucking pretentious when I say this but like
I really want
that
Pull that like the big
some of the big twitch indies do
or like
Like I just I want to be the person that like everybody
Knows is like cool and chill and you could talk to me and hang out and we can always collab and
um
And just like just have a bunch of fucking friends. Like that's all I want. I just want a bunch of fucking friends
In the industry it would be cool just to like kind of have that sort of
Like I don't want to be as famous as iron mouse, but like have a sort of like air about me, you know
Like tomah. Yeah
Tomah's cool. I love tomah. She sends me tiktoks all the time. I can't keep up with all the tiktok. She sends me
I
Knew at a place here. I saw a robot taking the debut. Uh, yeah, I need to rewatch
I was thinking that because I was cleaning and I was like I found my robotech discs
And my dad let me and I'm like oh, I need I should rewatch these
Um, I haven't watched robotech in a very long time
I already found your cool. So I think you're getting there. Thanks
Uh, tomah is a tiger. Oh, no, that's uh, toto. Tomah is um a monkey little monkey. Yeah
Oh, yeah, she'd be a knower. Yeah, that's what I want. And yeah, like I've said this before you're watching the hollow justice debut tomorrow
Probably I usually wait for them to debut
Ayo
Oh, thanks. What the fuck dude?
You didn't have to do that
Thank you
Can we get some can we get some chads in the chat for doki? How they am?
Oh
Very nice. Thank you so much. I appreciate that so much. I hope so. I want to make you guys proud. I want to be
I want to be the best for you for you guys and I want to be the best for the community
You know, I want to I want to make a difference
And I know on the way there I'll make mistakes. I'll learn I'll grow and all that stuff
Fia, what are you doing? She's scratching my chair. But yeah, you know, I want to do that
um
Again, my only fear is that people won't want to spend time with the girls and vealer and myself because of the content we do
We're already feeling it. Um
for some things
like
I really want to be friend
people and other agencies, but I
I know that
because of
who we are who strani was that
You know, we might not be afforded some friendships, but yeah
It is what it is
uh, it's water under the bridge for all of us, but
This sucks
You know, I'm that type of person who I want to be friends with everybody
Because I have a desire to be liked
Yeah, yeah, it's just the nature of business. This is the nature of agencies
um, it's the nature of you know
Some people seeing us like it was a competition, although I don't really see it that way like they were like, oh
My melody better my melody
Uh project melody better watch out for realer. No girl. I just want to learn from her. Are you kidding me?
This is like I ain't competition to fucking project melody. No
I don't do half the shit she does. I like to learn how she does her stuff though
That'd be fucking cool and with con tail VA and all the girls from twitch
playing
um
He's a wild take a while to get on the fucking level, you know
The only thing that we're doing differently is that we just have naughty ASMR and we say the the quiet shit out loud
Most of the girl like yeah, that's yeah
And I'm happy because I thought there was some
That wouldn't like us, but they they started interacting with us now. So I'm hopeful
I
Thank you friends. Did you make you'll be loyal? I hope so
I don't I'm not again. I said I'm the type of person like if something's wrong
Like I'll I'll confront somebody so because I hate drama. I just I just want people to be happy
I just want everybody to be okay and be happy and be friends
And that's why like I I asked like my gen mates a lot of questions annoyingly like how they're feeling how they're doing
um, because I just want to make sure we're all on the same page because
uh, I just want to make sure that they're okay and
Like everybody's doing all right because I care about them. I care about how they're feeling how their mental health is
Um, you had your fill of trauma there. Yeah, exactly. Yeah being a commentator was
very stressful it was
I can't even explain to you how stressful it was just like the hate
um
The shit that I went through dealing with people
And it's funny because now I get to see them get karma now that are in the con that were in the commentary community
And it's it's very nice to see it
People who treated me like shit, um
Just for being a girl trying to do shit
uh
Should be doing wellness checks I do though like I'm like I did that at my job too before I left
Like I would check in with everybody and be like, hey, how are you doing?
Or if somebody seemed down I'm like tell me what's up and they're just like I'm fine. I'm like don't fucking lie to me
When you get bigger friends aren't just friends business relationship from what I've heard
But like I don't want that
if like I don't
I don't see collabs as like a business transaction
Unless they explicitly say this is a business transaction
um, I will probably only collab with people that
I like I am acquaintances with or I am on friendly terms or I do consider my friends or my best friends
um
Because like I want to hang out with you. I don't want anything from you
You know like I don't
I'm not doing this
For like monetary gain or popularity
like if
If a big ass vtuber was like, hey, you want to hang out
I'd mostly be fucking sides because this person wants to hang out with me
I don't care about their audience size like and same thing for me
Like I don't care if you have only five people watching you if I know you're cool. I watch your streams. I've you know like
I'll hang out with you. Like, you know, like I'm not gonna let that stand in the way
It isn't a business transaction to me
But again, I respect the people who do believe that like I'm not gonna be like oh my god. You're just a bitch. No, that's stupid
Everybody's entitled to like how they go about things. Um
If I were to to collab with like some girls from other agency and they're like
We're doing this because management told us to I'd be like ow, but okay
Let's then I'll try to have the best fun that I can. I don't that's not hasn't happened
So I don't think that's happened. It has not happened, but like it's just this is the hypothetical. Um
It's time to start streaming so
Um, am I fine? Um
I'm okay
Like again, I'm very honest with you guys. So like I've been in a little bit of pain for my fibro
I've had a couple headaches
um
It's been tough
Leaving my job. I don't really think it's settled in yet
because I've been there for almost six years that job meant so much to me and
Saying goodbye to people was hard. I'm surprised I didn't cry. Um
It I'm not good with change
and what worries me the most is
I tend to get really isolated
And so I was only going back to work
So that I wouldn't isolate myself and self isolate because I tend to do that when I'm I'm feeling down
um
but
I realized I was just feeling more tortured being there like I was
Really starting to resent the work I was doing
Um, but otherwise I'm fine like
Yeah, like I miss hanging out my parents. I need to go see them. I did hang out with them a couple days ago
But yeah, I need to hang out with my friends. I was supposed to hang out with Salem, but I didn't feel good. Um
I needed to sleep
I didn't go over her house
And then like so yeah, my goals are really just to leave my house
Because I tend I like I have been agoraphobic in the past where I didn't leave my house for six months
And that wasn't good for me. It really wasn't it's not good for anybody humans humans are
Humans are pack creatures. We need to talk to we're very we need to hang out with other people
And that's I like I
V-Jubing does give me energy because I can talk to you guys
But sometimes it's good to be face-to-face with people, you know
Um
I
Left my old job the first week was just a haze. It's up the best that we're had in previous eight years
Uh for me, I've haven't I've been sleeping like fucking shit
I've only been sleeping a couple hours
Uh
I can't stay asleep. I have really fucking weird dreams
Um, and I'm a very lucid dreamer so I remember every fucking dream I have. Um
Yeah, it's just I'm in a weird state. I'm just I just feel I just feel off
You know mercury's and Gatorade. No, I have no idea fucking retreat mercury's and retrograde. Um
It's weird dreams. No, not the not the fun dreams. I have had a couple though
Sorry, I'm stretching. Um
Let me make a day and just go outside
Yeah, and like that's why like it took so much energy from me just to fucking go to the grocery store today
That's why I know that like I need to be outside more. Um, also it was just really hard carrying everything up
I've it I it's hard to carry groceries
several flights
um
And then I had to drag my bed frame upstairs and that shit is probably like fucking 50 pounds and
And I swear every time I picked up picked it up. I was getting abs and really buff
And then yeah, yeah, and even in terms of like streaming stuff. Um
It's it's a new thing to have so many eyes on me. I'm used to having like a concurrent viewership of
Like 30 people
like max
I remember on my debut when I debuted as Rena with my little chibi model
I got rated with 200 people and I will chat myself and now I have a concurrent viewership of that. So it's very
It's very weird adjusting to it the amount of attention
that I get
um
I'm used to kind of passing under the radar and kind of being the support
in the shadows type
Like I I'm always there to like lend a helping hand but to be on the forefront
It's very interesting. It's a very new experience to me. I think I'm handling it. Okay
The first week was a little bit rocky. Um, you know, I said some stupid shit
Uh, oh my god, Rena. What the fuck Rena? Can you go lay in your bed? Please?
Okay. Well, never mind. Ow. We just stepped on my tit. Thanks. I love that
Thank you for stomping on my nipple
Um mirror about me here and I'm happy. Oh, that's nice. Mara is such a sweetheart
Me and my plus girls are such sweethearts. We have a collab with them next week spoiler. Um, can't wait
uh
But yeah, now you're the protagonist it's like
Literally though, it's like I'm like, oh
Joining the alert would never happen to me because that's like a dream come true and like that would be a fairy tale and
A lot of my problems would be solved if this happened and then it happened and doesn't feel real
still like it feels
Like I'm gonna dream and I'm gonna wake up and
Be disappointed that I'm still stuck at my fucking job
But then I pinch myself and I have to remember that I'm here
As we discover you may plus they're pretty cool. Yeah, they're so sweet
They deserve a lot more
Viewership than they do like they they do. They're so talented. They're so funny
Most is a fucking right
Um, should have been me not him
I love you. Oh fucking where'd you come from bitch? She's just coming out of nowhere
She's just like me you my plus mention
Um, I don't know you too and
I've been here. Oh, yeah, I we talked like 20 minutes ago. You just lurking. She's lurking
Um, yeah, the most uh, the most of sliding in my dm. She's like, hey, you want to be friends and I'm like, yeah, bitch
I love that shit. That's my favorite
um
She's cool as hell
Please don't wake up. We'll stop existing
Hey, most of her bad mouth. Thank you. Um
Yeah, bad mouth thing about how much of a bad bitch you are
Uh, we all the girls are sweet. Um
Yeah, it's just it's and then also like dealing with hate has been interesting
um as a vtuber
It is a lot more manageable because as a commentator, I was like hit every day with that shit. So it was pretty desensitized
um, and I think
I've learned over time
to handle hate better
um
But then sometimes I'm like, I do get baited and I respond to trolls like I'll admit that I can be stupid like that sometimes
Um, mostly because I'm trying to be out of the goodness of my heart answer like an on what I think is an honest question when it isn't
um
or
or a
Yeah, or um
respond to something that I think is genuine, but
A genuine critique, but then I'm like, oh wait, no, it's not my back is cheap
um
Yeah, I just
Hmm
Like I'm learning not like when I don't like something I don't need to acknowledge it
When something bothers me don't want to just block and move on. That's it's really interesting
We're stroding your chat. That's pretty good
Yeah, don't feed the trolls. Yeah, and it's like because I'm like I'm a little fucking brat and bitch sometimes sometimes I'll bait the trolls
I've done that before and I'm like
Um, what I did that before is Rina and I'm like, oh fuck should have done that
But you live you learn and you live whatever the fuck you make mistakes that you fucking learned from them
um
and that's what
I think like
What we do as a company it's like we'll make like a small mistake and then we'll adjust accordingly
um
And we haven't made a lot of those
But
I can't wait to see how we'll grow. I think we have a
We'll be learning a lot at least as a company because I've never worked in a group as a company before like an agency
um
And of course I've worked in many groups like and I've managed teams when I was in the training when I was in my job
So it's it's interesting to kind of
I really like just being able to support scrawny in her dream
um
And also be able to make my own content and like just like her giving me the green light on things and projects that I want
To do has been really cool. Um, I don't know if any of the girls have anything planned
But like I would support them if they did something and they asked me to be a part of it or they just wanted support
So it's it's it's nice. It's it is really nice
I'm learning to let things go. Yeah, like I don't hold on to things
I realize uh, I think that's a skill I have
I I don't hold grudges
um
Yeah, pretty optimistic about people there. Yeah, me too
scrawny stream is my dream exactly
exactly
I really think viewers gonna be big one day. Yeah
I can't wait till we like
Like I want to be the V show joe for whores. Like I want to be like
I want to just be able to like nepo
Scout fucking huge lude tubers and be like come be a whore with us
Be fucking hilarious
Um, but yeah, like I know scrawny has a lot planned for us deals sponsorships
She's she literally wants the best for us and I couldn't ask for a better mom
A better vtuber mom
uh
The pop-up and pop cherries. Oh god, but um
Yeah, it's just
It's really cool. I'm very thankful
It's really nice hanging out with you guys
Too small be a lure be the whole live of vtuber lude tubers
I don't want that though. Like I don't want to be whole live of lude tubers
Um
Yeah
I'm trying to throw cops caught until vk. That'd be cool
Be like it was her she was queen in my lure
Um
I don't want to be that big because I was thinking about it because I was just like, okay
Like what if
um
And don't take this the wrong way this hypothetical that I thought of it was only because
the girl the
the
Debuts popped up that I thought of this and not in a negative way. Just like how would I handle it?
I'm like, okay. Let's say
in like four years
For three years velar
um
Ended operations
I'm like
Would I try to get in the hall alive? No
One because the content I make
two because of all the eyes on me
uh
three
I don't think I'm entertaining enough and like I don't
I don't know. I just like being small. I just like I that's why I hope velar lasts forever because I just want it
I don't know how to explain it, but I hope you guys like understand what I'm saying. It wasn't it's not
I don't care about the money
Either that's not a motivation. It's nice. It's an added perk
like
but
I
For me
Being a streamer was my passion into what makes brings me joy and makes me happy if I and then I was
So fucking miserable when I wasn't streaming for the last few years
It was so fucking shitty. I realized how much I missed it when I when I was rena
um
when I became
When I did my first stream as rena, I realized how much I missed it and then when I had to be
Quiet and be underground for a couple of months
Uh while I was transforming into my ultimate form shiwi
I was literally dying inside because I missed talking to my community. I missed talking to people. I missed making stuff
Because uh, like I had so many plans and I'm like, oh my god. Like I just wanted to get shit done. Um
It was a core profile. No, no, no. I was never in an agency before this. Uh, I was indy. I was a twitch indy
Very small twitch indy
um
I do and I already said this stream I caught until VA collab would go hard. Yes, it would
I don't know if she would want to talk to me though
Again, I'm so small
Oh, I'm gonna tell you when you're for five hours. Has it been five hours or shit?
I get it. We could be more comfy this way and it gives you flexibility. Yeah
The dichotomy between wanting success and wanting a nice small community. Yeah
Like I could always get a job
like
Worst comes to worst. I could get a job if like I wasn't making enough streaming and like that's fine
I'm up as long as I get to stream. That's all I care about
She loves us. I do. I'll say it. I love you guys. I love streaming
Fuck you
Bitch
Don't let it get to your head
Contale would simp for you on god. I highly doubt that I'd be simping for her
Overgrowth with the selfish part of me hopes. Oh you guys fucking talk her so fast. Um, it's the most like this intimate vibes are immaculate
Yeah
And like yeah, that's why like I've seen a lot of people have that same sentiment
Like they want us to be successful, but they want you want to get keep us a little and so I totally understand that
Um, but then
Then you think and I know you guys think this like why would I want to stop somebody else from experiencing what I'm experiencing right now?
What if she helps somebody or what if
like
She brings a smile to somebody having a bad day. That's what I want you to remember when you you think like that
um
Like what if we bring so much change to the vtuber community then another
Agency pops up that does similar content to ours and you find you're
The fucking love of your life in comey in comeyoshi and that one or like what if like because so many so many things can happen
like you can branch and
you know
all that
Still keeping my ego in check. Don't worry
Uh intimate chats of the soul. So yeah
I like about vtuber is the chat interaction, which is why I like indie so much. Yeah, I loved I liked I like streaming
Because I love doing chat interaction. That's why I'm frustrated with youtube because it's it's hard to do a lot of chat interaction
That's my like channel points on twitch
um
Have a plan make it easy
on her to destroy a thing
yeah
I did like um
I want to be part of honey kins
Like murder mystery thing that she has going she needs like 15 vtubers for it. So I was like, please please
um
Yeah, I like I'm afraid to ask people to hang out because I don't want to seem like I'm clout chasing because I just
It's just that now that I'm an agency vtuber with a brand
People are more likely to say yes because if I was a fucking indie
No one would say yes to hanging out with me
I don't want to hang out because I want popularity. I just want to hang out because I think your content's cool
So I'm like, oh if I slide into a k like so and so's dms. Are they gonna think I'm a clout chasing leechy bitch?
I'm like, I hope not
I just want to hang out with you because I think you you and your content is cool
Felt yeah
um
I don't yeah, I just don't want
I want to make connections, but it's it's it's it that's what holds me back
Um, and then when I feel a little bit stupid when like someone doesn't respond and I know they've seen it
But I'm like, hey, it's it is what it is. Like I can't
Change how they feel if like they're like, oh, I don't like her. She's kind of like and she's fucking
Because I know like another thing people are like, um, some people are put off about I've heard somebody say that
um
My model makes them uncomfortable, which makes me kind of sad
But I understand because like if you're not into bdsm and I have a fucking ball gag as a choker and
Uh shabari ropes and my boobs are a fucking huge, you know
um
And some people don't like a very sexualized. Why am I so small because I'm because I'm fucking
Because I'm leaning back
Here I'll lean I'll lean nice and close to you. I'm so short
I'm like trying to do this and lean but also like move myself up
So I can like yeah, okay, that's a little bit better. Um
Oh, this is scared of the drills
Reach out just bring a plant. Yeah here with the um big bobs scare you. Oh, well stay away from big bobs
so short
Yeah, I think my model is amazing too. Like when I saw it the first time I was like my mouth fucking dropped
I wish I was on a video call with strawnee because then she would have been laughing at me. Um,
What do you mean that is inside?
I'm scared you were personalities. I don't know maybe that's why that's why I'm like
I debate so often if I should really reel myself in
Because I don't want to put people off
Um
These people just want to hang out through the ones to be valid. Yeah, that's why I fucking love that you may plus girls so much
Because they gave us a chance, you know
They're like, yeah
Um, and I know like sponsored watch alongs don't uh mean anything when it comes to like lasting relationships in the v2
Bing community, but we were turned down by a lot of agencies. Um for that
And I can say that strawnee's already fucking talked about it. Um, but you may plus was like yeah
And like it was really fucking cool of them to accept
Because we're nobody's yeah, we have a little bit of pull because
of just like the content we make but
We're still a brand risk being not safe for work. That's why
Feel silly when there's so many skimpy jiggly models of the gags curious people. Yeah, yeah, you know, I think
I
Yeah, I I feel like
I I think
In like a couple months will be a little bit more settled in. We love you girls. We love you too
Um before mariah coming in college too
Honestly, yeah, like I was chatting in rem's chat. Um, I've been like making funny jokes with uh,
nova
So like I'm like they're the v4 mariah girls are so fucking cool to me to be honest, uh, their debuts
Honestly blew me out of the fucking water like all like all their debuts so far and before mariah
Um have blew me out of the water
Um, I remember watching serena's the first time when they actually made the company
Her singing voice was amazing. I
I
Was so amazed by it and then just the newer girls their debuts are so creative
They're such a creative group. Um, they're such a such a nice
bunch of people
um
And the mythos girls are also you have fucking facade and rated me the other day and I was like, oh shit, okay
That's cool
and that
And that like and I always see like as a raid a raid as like a little olive branch like hey, please like
I like you. I want to send my
My viewers to you and I always appreciate that
Um, I miss abby kiddo. Oh, yeah same she
It's a real bummer, but I'm proud of her. Um, because she
Got an opportunity, but she was honestly doing things that a lot of people did not do in the community in terms of skits
Um, and just her format and I thought that was very unique about her
Uh, and then yeah her and biscotti
um
Very talented people, but you know when life affords you
Amazing opportunities. You gotta you gotta get them and it's amazing that brave group allows them to do so
so
The scientist debut was insanely. You're not to the yes. Like I was like, what the fuck is this? This is crazy
Um, yeah, raids raids are nice. The the redirects are cool
I'm sorry with costume for the lore moment. Remind me of the moment from the
Um, yeah, I was laughing at uh, alias is v2 apology thing. I was dying at that actually that was really funny. Um
Came in from that raid. Oh, okay. That's funny. That's cool
Sounds like she found a little path into comedy. Yeah, I mean, I I generally I'm wondering what she got into like it
It for her to leave, but you know
It's very interesting
I mean it was and also like she was so great to her portuguese fan base her brazilian fan base. I really think
um, she really paved the way for um
Brazilian vtubers
Oh
Yeah, I hope I hope yeah, I hope the girls are okay. Um in her leaving
And I just yeah, I just wonder what will be next for a lot of the smaller agencies in the community
um
like
Yeah, pixeling just debuted around the same time as us
um
What was it isn't like idle doing another gen or um, or was that or did I see that in a dream?
I can't remember. Um
I know they did like uh idle. Yes, which was really fucking cool
I'm brazilian. That was so cool. Yeah, like she she always
I always appreciated that she always did her her tweets in english and in portuguese
I'll on core. Yeah
Yeah, no not on core. Uh, the gen three. Yes the gen three. Okay. I'm not I'm not going insane
Uh, so I I look forward to their debuts, too
I'll be a little shiblit
Shiblit. I like that. I should have called you my shiblits
Sounds like shitlits
Sounds like cheek lays cheeklets cheek lays
You may know one day she has a recognizable voice. Oh, you know, she definitely does
um
She fucking
Imagine she shows up in fucking holo. Holy
That's like the chaser. I would lose my fucking mind. Um
Same brain so yeah
Me and mercy say to share the same brain cells so often
Like I think it's like so many times we've like gone to
Like message each other and we're like, oh shit wait and because like I was about to talk to you
And then like we'll talk about like the same thing at the same time
In the our journal part of the discord and we're just like
People with theorizing about holo and it happens. It'll be so reactive like live tweeting. Yeah
Yeah, um, I kind of feel like with one of them being a really former high profile
um
Artist in indie I feel like
That this
Honestly, this has started happening a couple months ago though. Everybody's kind of been talking about pls
um
I feel like going forward people be able to talk more freely about them
Because those connections just don't go away, you know
Uh, if when you're like very well known people recognize your voice
You have a lot of friends. It's yeah, it's hard to be like
Of course like n da's it gives this and you can only you can share so much
Oh, you can only share so much and that's fine, but I feel like
That
That will change and I don't think that's because of us. That's it's already been the in the
In the works and the v2 being community that taboo kind of
Not being a thing anymore, but I think like we're one of the first groups to normalize it
Which is cool
PLs often have the same save some corporates. Yeah, exactly. Like I know
Usually like people in the new idol wave are probably gonna be bill
I already know that we have recently graduated vice versa
Because you know v2 being community tends to recycle their
Fucking talents. Um, I think v for morai
Is one of the more recent ones where there are people that I don't know. I didn't know about before
Or some but and I'm very thankful for strongy giving us a chance because I know I was a nobody
Zura was very small
I see was very small
uh, so
And mercy was like a little like medium-sized and um, I mean was larger, but uh, like she
Gave us a chance and when she did see big names applying. So I appreciated that a bunch
Um, because I I never thought I was going to break into the industry because
People were kind of just going through the same
You know jump and jive of getting the same talents over and over if someone graduates just moves to another company
And I'm like am I ever
What is what is going to set me apart?
And let get me in especially if there's nepotism people just hire their friends. So
It was it was very I
After if I didn't get into velar, I probably wasn't gonna apply to any more companies anymore
Um, I was probably just gonna focus on being indie. So I'm very happy that I'm here
Mm-hmm cynical. Yeah, but
Be a bit cynical, but it's like when you see a pattern
And it's it becomes a habit like what else can you think, you know
Not that I like fault the people in the industry for that
It's better to you like you know what you're investing in and you know how somebody acts and they already have a good track record in history
Why would in experience? Why would you not hire them? Like that's it's to be a stupid
Businesses and not to why would I take a risk on some random nobody from twitch?
um
That doesn't have a lot of content creation under the belt
Where someone who's an agency for two years recently left like I
It's an it's a no-brainer. So I don't I don't blame it at all
But then there's people like strani who want to you know develop talent
And take chance and she had faith in us and I appreciate her immensely for that immensely
Did Amy give a lot of I don't know you'd have to ask her that
Yeah, you'd have to ask her that I I don't know and I
um
Yeah, I'll be honest with you. I don't know a lot of the other girls motivations for applying
My motivation again was I wanted
It wasn't really for me. I just wanted to support
Strani and I know I can be a good entertainer and yapper, you know, um
And
Yeah, I just I just wanted to support her
I wanted to make change in the community and I saw her as a force for change and I wanted to support support that
Um as for the other girl. Yeah, I have no idea what their motivations were for joining
Maybe they wanted to do more adult content. Maybe they wanted to grow their audience. Maybe they wanted a brand
Um, maybe they wanted more support. I think yeah, I feel like for some of them. It's probably like support
um for projects and stuff so
Glad you're here since detail kind of directed me to be alert. Yeah, it's like a yes detail has been really sweet
She's given us a bunch of shout outs that collab with her was really cool
um
I think I want to be a part of a group that too. Um, I feel I think
I'm
I forget somebody one of the girls did mention that like I just wanted to be a part of a group
And I can't remember who it was, but I know that was definitely a part of somebody's motivation
um
Amy, yeah
She is but like let's not talk about her stuff. Um, just because it's not my place to speak on it
Um, I'll talk about mine, but I won't talk about the other girls because it's not my place. It's not it's
I don't have any right to talk about it
Uh, scrawny knows how to pick them. It seems she does so she has an eye
for for talent
Um, yeah
She beats literally sorrow. I think more important than the size of the proof
There's a work ethic showing that you the library consistent work is reassuring that it lasts
Yeah, that's why scrawny was a little bit confused because she's like, how do you know so much and do so much?
But you've only been around for six months and then I explained to her in my interview
That I technically was around longer than that and I had more content creation on my belt. I just applied with this
version of myself, um
Although again the version before
My past life was just me and the flesh. So there's no point doesn't make sense to apply as my flesh version
um
And I was very deter I in my audition video. I just kind of expressed how
Determined I was to help in just how much I would be a hard worker. I didn't do some people
People asked like did you how did you like what sexual thing did you do to get in? I didn't do anything
remotely naughty besides be like
like make a
silly like joke
I just read I
um
I just introduced myself played some clips
Uh, I read all the characters voice lines and different voices that I do and then
Because I I I didn't really have a set person
That I wanted to be in the company. So I trusted strongy to cast me for the right role and I think she did
um
It's funny. I kind of knew I would be ropes like I looking at the silhouette
I was immediately attracted to it
I thought I was going to be cast as like I see to be honest with you because of my past life, but um
But I I just fucking knew deep down. It's really weird
Like for the long stream, she'd be yeah, of course. I mean I said that not sure if she's the only one
Context I don't know it. Um, yeah talk to him if you want to know 100%
I don't even really hate cold
She be jorked it. Yeah, I jorked it
She has a lollip because I used to be a lolly
Does he know?
People think your auditions was poor. Yeah, which makes me laugh because literally I'll tell you what I did in my audition
I introduced myself
I played one clip
I continued to introduce myself. I played another funny clip
I continued to introduce myself. I played an asmr clip
Um, that's what they do
I talked
I did some voice acting
And then I told my commitment to be a lure and that was literally it
That was literally the audition
No, no, yeah, I didn't do any Mongolian throat singing. I was made I made sure to keep that away. I didn't do any yodeling
Don't make jokes aside. I think you fit her perfectly. Yeah
What sassy thing did you do bro joining a corpo even spice seems exactly I was very professional um in my
Uh audition video and I also was very professional for my interview because I didn't know if I was interviewing
Um, who I was interviewing for who I was interviewing with
um
Because I didn't think it would be strong. I thought it would be just the management management team
But it was actually just her telling me. Oh, yeah, you were our first choice. You saw you. Here's your model. You made it in
Sign this nda
And read the contract and let us know
You have a week to do it
Uh, yeah, she gave us a long time to look over the contract if we um
Tell like a lawyer look at it and stuff
Um, which was very nice of her. She was very patient. Um
I don't know if I'm allowed to say that but I just did so I think I think that's fine
Um, how hard did you would fit it? I would do that was so hard. Um
You didn't split and no, I didn't spit in sharny's mouth. Um, but yeah, it was one interview
Uh, they're always reviewed contracts. Yeah, exactly. Um
Yeah, it was just one interview
She was really nice. I had prepared like a whole thing
Like questions to ask how to respond
um
Very professional
I even like dressed up did my makeup in case she wanted to do like a video call and then
I realized yeah, it was just a normal way to go. Um
But yeah
How was the couch
Always a good sign when your player encourages you to fully examine your contract. Oh, yeah, she was very like, please look at it
Like please make sure this is what you want. Um, I read it over multiple times
it
She all says that her and a lawyer did a good job writing something up
I'm not allowed to say that I've read I had time to read my I don't know. I don't know if this shit works
You know hard it is for me to keep secrets
That's why I'm like, if any of you guys have any surprises, don't fucking tell me because we'll tell everyone
You know how hard it was just not say that I was she be it was so hard for me
I was dying. I changed the password on my account to my twitter
I had my friend change it and not tell me
So I couldn't get back in so I could so I wouldn't fucking accidentally sub tweet something
Or like something
Because I was so happy and when you're so happy you want to share it with people that you love
And so I wanted to share it with my community because I love my community and I knew they would be happy for me
Oh, yeah
It's that bad, huh?
I'm getting eepy 10 30 I should probably go to bed
Need to make some tea
Um, but should you be in spoilers domo?
Honestly though, that's that's that's me. That's why I
Like I already know a bit about gen 2 and it's very hard not to talk about it
But um before I go to bed, did you guys have any more questions for me?
I don't mind answering any questions you guys have
You guys know I'm a very open book and I love to yeah
And barely play games. I am a just chatting streamer. I have to fart
I don't know if you heard that whisper of a fart. I really hope you didn't
No spoilers for gen 2
You mean how strong he hasn't even said that gen 2 is in the works
Yes, she has
She definitely said the gen 2 is in the works
Huh, can you pronounce?
Yeah, I'm starting to can't stop talking about gen 2. She's so excited. Yeah, she's talking about fucking gen 3
It's talking about gen 3
Um
I had to be like can you stop
I'm like strani. You're making me feel bad. I'm like you're already conceptualizing gen 2 and 3. What about me?
She's like, no, no, no, no, I don't want you to feel bad. And I'm like, no, I'm kidding. I'm excited
Can I please help? And she's like, yes, I'm like, thank you slam girl. I was shot down, but it's fine
Okay, wait, how do you pronounce it then?
How do you pronounce it?
Yeah, I think me and strani are so like it's kind of weird. She's just in a Scottish font
She says she is gen 2 and gen 3 in games names for them. Yeah, exactly
I'm I'm gonna try to talk her down from some of the names. That's all I'm gonna say
I can't read
Leave me alone. I don't speak French that well
I mean squarel
I can't read I can't I can't I can't
Should give you some towns
In my area to pronounce
Talks about Jennifer with slides will be destroyed
Pretty sure she has rescued herself from naming future gents. Yeah
The reason it's a slime girl is because she's thinking of the name of a slimy slime hole
One of them accidentally docks you wait what?
Oh like that. No, um
So like
I'm not
Afraid to say like I live in America on the east coast
There's a lot of how hard to pronounce
Like towns and cities
Like all around along the east coast
So like especially in fucking New England
I
Guys don't fuck with fondle of bosom. I actually really want to bring back fondle of bosom
And she could be like a really touchy feely person
Games is a video game. She got the concept for oh, okay
In death a member of project wheeler has a name her name is fondle
Of the liberty city. Yeah
You look nice when you're just laying in bed instead of walking and stomping all over my booze
East coast represent somebody said they knew I was east coast because I talk so bluntly
And that I have an accent and I never fucking noticed that
Come on beat that. Please come back
You can just say come on beat it
beat
They're like she's I just like I've never been clocked on where I like where I'm from
before
And I didn't know that being blunt
Was a thing like they knew where I was from and I was like
Damn
I did not think that I also
I well, yeah, I use eastern. Yeah, that's fine. Um, and I also I talk fast
Because I know people from the south talk slower. Remember when I visited my grandparents in florida
um
They would like people I would talk to you that were that was like can you speed the fuck up?
Because you're talking
Like this. Oh my god was so fucking annoying
When you said you visited Montreal, that's more evident around the east coast. That's a good point
East coast is kind but not nice. Oh, yeah. No east coasts. We're fucking dicks
Especially massachusetts. That's why they call them mass holes
I always thought that was funny. They call them that
Yeah, new england people are cold, especially a lot of people are chill. Yeah. Yeah, a lot of people are chill
medicaid people are fucking uppity
try thing
North Carolina, georgia
They're kind of nice
carolinas are nice
Strings them and how much information is conveyed per second by different languages and accents, right? Yeah
Because you can literally like especially if you're in like the uk
You can clock someone's accent
Because they're all accents are by region
Like i'm sure you could probably look at a british
Vtuber and I wouldn't be surprised if a lot of british vtubers change their accents so that they don't
You don't know where they're from
The latel fiends are in our own special
We have to be chillin florida or else we'd melt
true
Got the opposite. It's not yin and yin only other field filipino side was british or something
No, i'm pretty sure i have american accent
yeah, i've got
Like i do have like i'll have an accent sometimes that slips out
And i don't know if a lot of people have like heard it slip out
Like obviously i'm from america
And east coast but i like sometimes when i get super excited
um
My or like frustrated or i just like really tired and my words slur together
um, i start to have
My accent comes out
but uh
Miss origan tipped 50 dollars
You're the first vtuber i've ever watched and you quickly become probably my favorite content creator period
Also could as three percent get get some donnie
Such good girls, thank you
Best girl
And they say hello, so yeah, no i'm that type of person like i'll like i'm also really bad with eye contact
um, i've always been bad with eye contact even in working in sales and
Being a lot more confident than it used to be. I just don't like looking at people. I don't know what the fucking tell you
i'm squirt
No, i'm kidding. Um, no, where am i?
And so i'll usually just like look down and smile
Um, but lately i've been trying to say hello to people
um
Um
Although like i remember going to the south and people are like too nice and i'm like stop talking to me
Like why are you striking up a conversation with me? I was at a wawa
I'm like and this guy like is like i'm getting coffee and i'm one of like the little station
And then this guy comes and starts talking to me and i'm like, uh
Why are you talking to me like you don't
You don't have to talk to me right now. Like can you please go away?
But like i've also adapted a skill that i've seen my dad do
Um, my dad has a special skill where he can be friends with about anyone
Uh, he finds common ground. He makes a joke
And then miraculously he just becomes friends with this person and then
He i might say becomes friends with everybody. I'm not even fucking joking
He'll talk he'll like catch a snippet of a conversation that someone's having on the street
Make a joke and then make the person laugh and then they're just friends
He like i forget what the fuck he did. So my dad really likes to drink bourbon. Um, he likes uh, he's a collector
um
And like if you go to my parents house, they look they're a bunch of fucking alcoholics because they just have a shit ton of bourbon
In this one side of the room, but it's it's it's not even like that
My dad just likes to collect and like have it not even drink it. Um
And so he goes to like this place
Strikes up a conversation just being really friendly and getting to know
They're like cracking jokes with the cashier
and then
Over the course of a couple weeks
He becomes like boys with the cashier and then the cashier hooks him up with like
Really like and like calls him ahead when they get in like good stuff
And i'm like what the fuck and i'm like, oh wait, it just pays to be nice to people because then they're nice back
So um
And then like i'm like, you know, so i'm trying to be more like my dad in that way and just be nice to people
Just fucking
It's cat hair in my mouth
um
And it's it's very like i think
There there's this um little girl in my building and i don't know why she likes me so much
Um, i think because i look like i should be like her sister or something. She's like this really cute um Spanish girl with curly hair
and
She saw me in the elevator one day
And she was wearing a bathing suit
And i'm just sitting there and like kids are great because they just like talk to you for no reason
and they just just because they just don't know like
Like social cues and i'm like just i literally look like a shit. I'm like in shorts
A sweatshirt a hood's up. I'm like i look like i'm fucking pathetic
homeless girl
my face is like
Messy and this little girl looks up at me and she's like
Do you like my unicorn bathing suit?
And i look at her and i'm like
And i
And i'm like, oh my god. Yes, it's so great. She's like see mom. She likes it
And then every time i see her
She always makes sure she says hi to me
and she's like and then um
She like ran over to me one day when i was in the lobby of the apartment building and her mom's like
Redacted come back and she's like i'm saying hi to my friend mom and i'm just like
And so i'm like, you know what i strive to be this child
That's really cute. It was really fucking cute. Um
She was really sweet. She's like i like the like the natural cuteness and curiosity of kids. This is so funny to me
Uh, and then like it happened again with like another kid
Uh, and i'm like, do i just have that like that face where like do you kid?
I'm like, i don't know if the kid's pity me or they're like, uh, you know what? I want to talk to her
I like i'm i'm going to pick up my door dash. I think it was like yesterday or the day before
No, it was definitely yesterday
And i get into the elevator and now it's super hot outside and we have a pool in my apartment and so people um
Like we're leaving to go to the pool. There's like four kids
Piling the elevator with their mom and then one of the the girls just starts talking to me and i'm just like
She's like, hey, it's really hot outside. Isn't it? We're going to the pool. I'm like, oh, wow. I hope you guys have a lot of fun
And they're like, okay. Bye as we get to the first floor and I go to go pick up my my uh my food
But it's just it was just it's this is sweet. It was just really sweet
Congratulations, you're a best friend now and it's like I've always been good with kids
I don't know why like I used to work at like a sermon camp. I used to be like a camp counselor and stuff
and um, I remember
There was this time where um
These girls were like arguing because they wanted me to like I was a better artist than I am now
um
Because I kept up with it and they're like, can you draw our monster high dolls?
So I would draw their monster high dolls and they would fight over whose doll gets to be drawn. It was so cute
um
I could smile with an awesomer expression in my private video the other day how they were like, oh, that's cute
It was like
What the fuck did I miss something?
If you think you look at that, oh, no, if you guys saw me be like, who is this little stinky rat girl
I looked like I was going to rob someone
Wawa you narrowed that down a bit. Well, it was a wawa because there's no wawa's in our area
Right from they don't we don't have wawa
So
It's like the little the little innocence of kids like they don't need like they're not rude
There's no malice behind what they say like they're just generally
Just talking to you like and it's just it's refreshing
But
Yeah, it's just like I want to be more like that like just be like hey
And that's why like that's what I'm gonna try to do in the v2 breed thing like community and shit
That's why like I'm trying to
Like be like hey, I'll do this thing with you or I'll do this collab or I'll do that
And it adopted me. Yeah, maybe I guess so
um
Oh, yeah, that's not what morgan said reminds me. Uh, I remember I went to like
uh
An event where I dressed up
Yeah, as in like a cosplay
um
And this little girl asked to take a picture with me and I literally wanted to cry and like other people wanted to take pictures with me
And I was just like, oh my god
Like they think I'm gonna I look cool enough to ask for a picture
And I was like, okay
It was it was it's nice
I know rena rena's looking at me like why aren't you in bed yet? She'd be piqued. Yeah, it's only downhill for me or guys
She'd be cool. I try to be cool
I
See me I try to be cool
I think I'm a cool cat cool rabbit, you know
I'm cool. Yeah, I can be cool. I can be hip with the kids, you know
I know about fortnight and um fortnight dances and v-wux and all that
Cool rabbit sheep. Yeah, exactly
Kids don't have souls. Oh, yeah, no, there's definitely some like kids that are like really fucking shitty out there
Like I don't want kids, for example. I like I don't want kids
One because I don't know if I didn't have kids because I don't know if I have falls less than over a century or not, but um
I also just like it's a lot to raise a whole ass child. Like I don't want to
Traumatize them and make them hate me
I know what I put my parents through so I don't want to put my child through that with me
Um, you know fucking children are expensive
That means like I'm 56. Where am I gonna find a dude?
Who wants to have kids with me?
I'm like, I don't I just don't fucking care. I just like having cats
I
Was at a con for some reason. There's a couple of people that cosplay that didn't want their photo taken. Oh, yeah
Sometimes you just go just to dress up and have fun. I got it. They just want to take pictures with their friends
right here
To be too boy, no show would be dope
I find you have a sort of effless cool with how Jenny when you are
you know, uh
I feel like that's actually not the first time someone said that to me not to toot my own horn
Um, people have always said I'm just really easy to talk to and that's why people tend to like
Accidentally overshare with me
Uh, uh, I'll just be like, hey, how are you feeling? They'd be like, um, you know
Try to make small talk and then I'm not the type of person who I just like walk away and be like, okay
Thanks for checking in. Um, I'll like like elaborate with my question. Raina. What the fuck are you doing?
She's rubbing against my monitor lady. Can you?
No
ma'am
I can't stop you
I'm too tired to reach over
It's your little twitchy, but what are you doing?
Hi, Raina
Raina's like lost weight and she looks so goofy. I mean she used to be super fucking overweight. She was like 17
Almost 20 pounds. Um
But she lost a lot of weight
Sadly because she went through a little depressing episode when her sister passed away, which I don't blame her and when I moved into my apartment
I took her with me. Um
Yeah, Raina, she's a little meow
um
So she's she's got a healthy weight now, but I miss her her chunky size
Oh you purring big mamas
Oh, yeah, she was she was a chonker because Siamese cats tend to overeat
She's my life stories, ma'am
Do you think your openness is a good thing or has it caused you unwanted problems?
um
I think some people probably wish that I was a little bit more
left things to the imagination or like didn't share
Like I know sometimes things I'll share something like I bet
someone has like
Like I said like I want a reduction and they're like, oh, why the
Ruin filtered. Why did she have to say that? Oh, no, but like I'm just telling you
You know just because I want to tell you
And like that's fine. That's okay
um
It is what it is or like I might say something like oh, I'm not gonna do this content
Like oh, why would you say that? Oh because I'm gonna be honest
Do you want to just be strung along and let on? No, like
If you want me to lead you on I'll lead you on I suppose sorry rena's are being against my microphone
um
I'm like this. I'm just how I am
Buenos dias shippies me fun time freddy. So what did I miss?
Buenos dias freddy
Well, buenas noche. It's night time for me freddy
It's night time for me
um
but I think people also
Are refreshed by my openness as a vtuber because vtubers usually constantly play as something or pretend to be someone or not or
And I think I I like how real I am. So I I think I'm refreshing in that
You know it if you don't like it, I can't stop you from not watching
I'm gonna fucking glue your eyes to the screen
You want to be led in a leash not in false sense
She won't make submissive crying a some more it's over
I
Realness of this whole company is refreshing. Yes, I agree with that because I feel like we're all very real
Like we're all very open
Which you don't get and I know that actually can put a lot of people off because you know
First some it might ruin the fantasy
And I understand that I can't disagree with you
um
But for some it kind of like makes it better. I don't know
Most of us appreciate it. It might be small, little minority who complain. Yeah
Yeah
um
And I do you want to say like who who complain their opinions are still valid. Um
I don't want you to ever think just because like we might disagree on something that
I fucking hate you. It's really hard for me to hate people
uh
Definitely open on the else
Open this asshole. Um rena. Can I please move you? She's like just sitting on me and I'm like uncomfortable
She's just you're not in a good position to sit on me lady
Thank you. I appreciate it. She's moved to the bed
um
I miss her and I thought you said Europeans
are still valid
your opinions
Europeans are still valid
um, but
They're not valid. Oh, no, okay. Um, like you're
You're still allowed to dislike me
I'll like the content or do how I talk or what I might do in the future or what the other girls do
um, but you just don't have to make it a habit to
Try to drag us, you know
You can just leave
Just shut your eyes and walk away from the computer, bro
Or just like look up that one Tyler the creator tweet
Hey, European people in chat. You're valid. I think they're all asleep right now. It's very late for them
Maybe I don't know what time is it for the our European friends
I'm probably gonna as mercy streaming today. I'll probably read into her
If you want fantasy, you probably have to find specific vtubers that do that
Some people just use models because they want to be secretive or have to set up stuff. That's true
I think
you know
I
I was totally prepared to like
play a character
Being in v alert an agency
But I think to be honest because of my audience and because of management and astronomy
I feel comfortable being myself. I think if I got into like a different company
I could be like say so I could be
You know play the character
Um, I did definitely kind of play a character when I was ran up
But I really do
Feel and I'm kind of just realizing this now that
I'm very much myself
As she be
It's very interesting
Is there is life? Oh, okay
Or maybe I can just like raid someone random
Make, you know, I've got to make those friendships those connections raid someone from
A different different company
In characters with the patreon audios are for yeah, exactly
Um, and then sometimes, you know, there's different roles that I play in the patreon audios
but
I hope you guys liked it by the way. Um, again, that was
This month is the first month that I recorded back in april and I've definitely learned a lot since then
so
I feel I feel like because I've recorded three months of audios in advance. Uh, I recorded june july and august
Uh, I I was gonna start september. I haven't done that yet. I'll probably do it soon. Um,
But the september audios will probably be a lot
Different than like because just because like the feedback I've gotten
Um, the advice I've gotten
So I feel like there'll be improvements like at least september on
uh, and then
You guys have also given feedback to like strani and stuff about like the scripts you want us to fill
Come and that's why like strani wants like, oh, we need to make a whole month of you
Just like straight dom like hardcore and I'm like facts. Please. Let's do it
That's what we give the people what they want. Give them the dom that they ask for
um, but yeah
Okay, oh, yeah, no, it's I've paced myself for that
um
I also
I have a lot of free time. Um, when I was out of work on leave and now since I'm just I've quit entirely
um
I so I just cranked them out. The other girls had a lot of other obligations
They had to do so like I finished a lot of my shit in the first month
Like I and then I was like, please strani throw most rough at me
So should you just get thrown scripts at me? Um and shorts at me to do
But yeah, don't worry about me. I don't
Me and strani
Like I attain to be as hard working as strani is she is the hard-working working autism
I don't have autism that I fucking know of
Um, but I am definitely inspired by her work ethic to work as much as I do
M's and the switches are eating good on them of facts
Yeah, like listening to them patriot, but I still need to listen to the second one more to finalize my feedback. Okay
I feel like I don't know why I just got the equivalent of like someone sipping wine be like
I need to finalize my feedback for this flavor
But yeah, I hope if you're going to sleep good night, um, I'm gonna raid someone
Let's see. Maybe we'll yeah, maybe we'll raid someone new. I don't know if anybody's streaming us late
Let's see
Yeah, me
I think I'm gonna raid Maeve. Yeah, she just hit 100k. I'm just playing Elden Ring
Yeah, we'll we'll raid Maeve. That's cool
from from, um
Inyo, yeah
Um
Trying to make new friends out here we we make we build in bridges
making connections
Um, but you know, I care about you guys. Thank you for letting me be an honest little bunny today. Um, sorry about
not streaming the game as much
Um, but it was giving me a lot of issues. I was just on top of you guys. I'm sorry if that bothers you
Um, tomorrow we'll be doing the uno collab. I am uh, I'm in there
So we'll be having a lot of fun with the girls and very, very, very, very, very excited
Just trying to join with them. Um
I always love doing collabs with them
Oh, yeah
Okay, smell better today
So